bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat hier les sénateurs ont
entamé l'examen du projet de loi relatif
aux soins psychiatriques dans un climat
particulièrement tendu c'est en effet la
première fois qu'un rapporteur
démissionne de ses fonctions la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales la centriste Muguette Dini a
donc été remplacée par Jean-Louis Laurin
sénateur UMP pour ajouter à la confusion
sur ce texte c'est la version adoptée
par l'Assemblée nationale qui est
arrivée hier en séance publique la
version amendée en commission des
affaires sociales ayant été rejetée les
sénateurs ont débattu de l'article 1er
la mesure phare de ce texte qui ouvre la
possibilité à à des soins ambulatoires
psychiatriques sans consentement c'est
donc la discussion de cet article
premier que je vous propose de revoir
tout de suite bonne matinée à
tous la science est reprise alors deux
am nous avons 25 amendements discussion
commune amendement 45 rectifié il est
présenté pour le groupe CRC par Isabelle
Pasquer merci monsieur le Président
euh hop je met mes lunettes ça va aller
mieux donc cet amendement vise à
supprimer les al alinéa 2 à 20 qui ouvre
la possibilité de préférer quasi
systématiquement des soins
psychiatriques en ambulatoire à toute
forme d'hospitalisation dans un
établissement de santé adapté alors
certes dostoyevski disait en son temps
ce n'est pas en enfermant ton prochain
dans une maison de santé que tu
prouveras ta raison mais ce n'est pas
non plus en l'enfermant dans une
camisole chimique à son domicile
personnel que tu pouveras et cetera si
la mise en place de soins psychiatriques
notamment les soins sans consentement
réalisés en ambulatoire peut apparaître
bénéfique pour le patient et
respectueuse de son autonomie
puisqu'elle se présente comme une
alternative à l'enfermement des
personnes atteintes de troubles mentau
en réalité c'est une disposition cette
disposition n'est qu'un trompe lœil en
effet la substitution des soins
psychiatriques imposés sous forme
ambulatoire à une hospitalisation
obligatoire n'aura aucune incidence sur
l'autonomie du patient car où qu'il soit
en hôpital ou à son domicile celui-ci
celui-ci sera toujours contraint de
subir des soins et quels soins à
l'évidence des soins médicamenteux
puisque'à domicile l'encadrement dont il
pourrait bénéficier dans une structure
médicale adaptée n'existerait plus de
plus en consacrant la possibilité de
dispenser des soins sans consentement à
domicile la nouvelle rédaction de
l'article l32 11 1 aura des conséquences
dramatiques pour les familles de ces
malades qui devront outre prendre en
charge les malades et veiller au respect
de l'obligation de soins du patient
assumer seul la responsabilité civil du
fait des malades qui leur seront confiés
de même si ces soins psychiatriques sous
forme ambulatoire sont censé favoriser
un maintien à domicile des personnes
atteintes de troubles mentaux cuid des
person malad qui sans famille ou ayant
rompu tout contact avec celle-ci feront
l'objet de soins sans consentement qui
veillera au respect de l'obligation de
soins et je ne parle pas de ceux qui
habitent dans des logements insalubres
d'ailleurs de manière générale les
familles restent perplexes quant à la
réalité pratique d'une prise en charge
de ces malades sous forme
ambulatoire ainsi comme en témoigne le
père d'une personne souffrante de malade
de mal maladie mentale cette loi est
inutile on nvoque ni l'accompagnement du
malade ni la question du logement on ne
traite que de la contrainte qui
accompagnera les personnes sous
contrainte qui lesé logera rien n'est
dit et cela nous devons aussi
l'entendre merci amendement 87 il est
présenté par Jacy
lomen merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à supprimer les alinéats
2 à 20 de l'article 1er alors mes cèg de
la commission des affaires sociales
reconnaîtront d'ailleurs cet amendement
qui avait été présenté par ma notre
collègue rapporteur initial et que nous
avions voté en commission parce que nous
étions d'accord avec nous avons donc
repris cet amendement le présent projet
de loi prévoit la création de soins
psychiatriques sans consentement sous
une autre forme que l'hospitalisation
complète c'est-à-dire en ambulatoire
voire à domicile si l'objectif de
diversification des modes de prise en
charge et louable les soins
psychiatriques sans consentement sous
une autre forme que l'hospitalisation
complète ne font l'objet donc unee
définition précise dans le texte et
soulève ainsi de nombreuses
interrogations par exemple que
contiendrait le protocole de soin
nouvellement édicté quels serait les
conditions de sa mise en œuvre quels
seraient les personnesabilités à avoir
connaissance de ce protocole que faire
si le protocole n'était pas respecté par
le malade autant de questions qui reste
en suspent alors même que le dispositif
doit entrer en vigueur le 1er août
prochain soit dans moins de 3 mois dans
ce contexte il n'est pas surprenant que
de nombreuses craintes aient été
soulevées par les praticiens et les
familles la première attrait à la
contrainte supplémentaire qui pèserait
sur le malade en effet la dérogation au
droit de de tout malade de consentir au
soins qu'il reçoit serait étendu dans la
mesure où la contrainte ne serait plus
seulement exercé au sein d'un
établissement hospitalier mais aussi
hors de ses murs autrement dit la
contrainte s'exporterait or par
définition la contrainte s'oppose au
consentement facteur pourtant essentiel
à la réussite des traitements
thérapeutiques relatif à la mentale je
le précisais d'ailleurs dans mon
intervention en discussant générale d'un
point de vue médical est donc primordial
d'encadrer davantage la pratique des
soins psychiatriques sans consentement
prenant une forme autre que
l'hospitalisation complète en outre dès
lors que les soins précités auraiit lieu
en ambulatoire voire à domicile le
contrôle de leur nécessité et de leur
proportionnalité devrait deviendrait
plus difficile s'ansuit logiquement que
le dispositif prévu par le projet de loi
est excessivement attentatoire aux
liberté publique la liberté individuelle
d'aller venir le droit au recours le
respect de la vie privée la protection
du domicile sont autant de droits
fondamentaux insuffisamment réaffirmés
et garanti par ce projet de loi enfin
envisager la pratique des soins sans
enconsentement en ambulatoire voire à
domicile nécessite de prendre en
considération l'organisation et les
moyens des services
médicau-psychiatriques le contexte
actuel est marqué par une insuffisance
de ressources et des difficultés en
matière de recrutement notamment
d'infirmière voir aussi de psychiatre
ainsi le système d'expertise sur lequel
repose le jeu des certificats on a vu
qu'ils étaient nombreux et les examens
effectués par le collège des soignants
nouvellement créés requierent une
augmentation et une meilleure
répartition des effectifs sur le
territoire en somant l'état de ce projet
de loi il est tout à fait inapplicable
plusieurs intervenants nont dit par
conséquence il serait déraisonnable
voire irresponsable de valider le
dispositif envisagé par le gouvernement
qui consiste à étendre la pratique des
soins psychiatriques sans consentement
en dehors des établissements
hospitaliers l'ampleur et la portée
d'une telle réforme sont trop importants
pour faire l'économie d'une réelle
concertation approfondie avec les
praticiens les familles à ce stade de la
réflexion qui n'en est qu'à ses
prémisses il est préférable d'en rester
à l'hospitalisation sans consentement
assorti de sortie décès qui est
d'ailleurs la situation actuelle lorsque
la santé mentale du patient le permet
d'où l'amendement que je viens de
rappeler merci amendement 477 tractifié
madame paayette
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
propose une modification rédactionnelle
du titre du chapitre 1er
en effet il semble regrettable que
figure dans le titre comme dans le
contenu du projet de loi un nombre
considérable de locution comme fait
l'objet pour des personnes souffrant de
troubles mentaux mais qui n'en demeure
pas moins des personnes cette maladresse
est indiscutablement péjorative et
mérite d'être
corrigé merci amendement 5 monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis
oui monsieur Président chers collègues
l'article L 3200 11- 1 du Code de la
santé publique indique qu'une personne
ne peut recevoir des soins sans
consentement hormis les cas prévus par
la loi et notamment par les chapitres 2
et 3 du présent titre cette formulation
apparaît trop imprécise dans un souci de
lisibilité de la loi il convient de
dresser la liste exhaustive des
dispositions législatives qui permettent
de déroger au principe du consentement
aux soins cela permettra en outre de
supprimer un notamment ce qu'affectionne
particulièrement vous le savez la
commission des Lois du
Sénat merci amendement 46 il est
présenté par le président ficher
oui mes chers collègues le projet de loi
que le gouvernement nous propose
d'adopter n'est pas à une contradiction
prêt il propose en effet en plus des
soins réalisés sous contrainte en
secteur hospitalier de les réaliser hors
les murs or il ne s'agit pas de les
réaliser au sein des centres
médicau-psychologiques ni même des
établissements de secteur auxquels nous
sommes attachés mais en ambulatoire sans
qu'il n'y ait d'ailleurs ce projet de
loi une quelconque précision sur cette
notion
d'ambulatoire on sait toutefois que ces
soins ambulatoires ne reposeront pas sur
le secteur ou sur les CMP que votre
politique n'a cesse d'étouffer
financièrement au point que de plus en
plus de ces structures ferment jour
après jour tout laisse à croire que les
soins ambulatoires seront en réalité des
soins réalisés au domicile du patient et
de ses proches et reposeront sur un
suivi assuré par des médecins libéraux
tout cela n'est pas pour nous rassurer
lorsque l'on connaît la situation de la
médecine psychiatrique libérale marqué
d'abord et avant tout par un
vieillissement des professionnels et les
listes d'attente pour y accéder et
encore je n'aborde pas la question du
nombre grandissant de psychiatres
libéraux optant pour le secteur 2 ce qui
nuit à des consultations réguli
indispensable pour le suivi
psychiatrique propre aux pathologies
dont peuvent souffrir les patients dont
il est question alors tout cela nous
conduit à proposer au travers de cet
amendement et cela dans l'intérêt du
patient qui doit être notre seul guide
dans la matière que les soins en
question soient dispensés dans des
structures spécialisées avec des
personnels compétents qu'il s'agit de
centres médicaupsychologiques ou de
hôpitaux de jour qui sont des lieux de
soins au sens large où l'on parle des
lieux où l'on mesure l'état du patient
des lieux de rencontre d'activités de
socialisation indispensable au succès
thérapeutique tel est le sens de cet
amendement merci monsieur le Président
amendement 280 la parole est à Alain
Milon merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit de modifier dans cet article 1er
les alinéat 12 à 15 et de leséer de les
rédiger de la façon suivante en
modifiant donc ainsi l'article
l321-2-1 du Code de Santé publique une
personne faisant l'objet de soins
psychiatriques sans son consentement est
prise en charge par tout les outils
thérapeutiques de la psychiatrie adapté
à son état cette prise en charge
peut-être dispensée dans des unités
d'hospitalisation temps plein dans des
unités alternatives à l'hospitalisation
temps plein des lieux de consultation
des lieux d'activité thérapeutique ou
dans le lieu de vie habituel du patient
lorsque les soins sont dispensés dans un
des lieux prévu au deuxièement un
programme de soins du patient est établi
par un psychiatre de l'établissement
d'accueil C cet amendement précise
monsieur le Président que les soins
psychiatriques destinés à des personnes
souffrant de toubres mentaux qui
altèrent leur capacité à consentir
peuvent avoir lieu indifféremment et
selon évaluation médicale à la fois dans
des unités hospitalières temps plein
c'est-à-dire 24h/ 24 et dans tous les
autres lieux où interviennent où
interviennent habituellement les équipes
psychiatriques pour les autres
malades
merci alors cet amendement 28 est
l'objet
d'un sous-amendement
ou d'un suramendement je sais pas mais
en tout cas appeler sous-amendement qui
est présenté par Monsieur Lauren à titre
personnel et non pas en tant que
rapporteur de de la commission merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président ce sous
amendement que je présente donc à titre
personnel vise à compléter l'excellent
amendement de d'Ana Millon qui clarifie
beaucoup le concept de soins sans
consentement hors hôpital et cette ce
sousamendement t à apporter de nouvelles
précisions d'abord je vous suggère de ne
plus parler de soins sans consentement
cette phraséologie mais un peu difficile
mais de soins psychiatriques auquels une
personne n'est pas à même de consentir
du fait de ses troubles mentaux je crois
que ce changement marque mieux qu'il
faut distinguer donc marque l'obligation
d'un côté qui est faite au patient de se
soigner et de l'autre côté les modalités
des soins qui seront discutés entre le
psychiatre et le malade en outre je vous
proposerai de mieux préciser les
conditions de modification du programme
de soin et de prévoir un entretien avec
le psychiatre et le malade au cours
duquel le médecin recueillera l'avis du
patient enfin le ce sous-amendement que
j'ai préparé prévoit aussi que le détail
des traitements médicamentux ne
figureront pas sur le programme de soins
j'espère ainsi que cette nouvelle
rédaction apaaisera par exemple les
inquiétudes qui peuvent se lever et
permettra d'avancer dans la recherche
d'un vrai consensus sur cette réforme
j'ajouterai aussi que j'ai intégré à et
j'en suis heureux aussi un amendement de
notre collègue donc monsieur CF qui
prévoit que le patient est informé de
son droit de refuser les
soins merci Monsieur Laurin amendement
47 il est présenté par Annie David
oui monsieur le Président avec cet
amendement 47 nous proposons de
supprimer par cohérence avec notre
amendement précédent les soins sans
consentement réalisés en ambulatoire il
y a eu à ce sujet important débat
l'Assemblée nationale le rapporteur du
projet de loi rappelant systématiquement
aux députés de l'opposition que les
soins ambulatoires n'étaient pas des
soins réalisés à domicile or l'article
14 que nous vous proposerons d'ailleurs
de supprimer est clair il prévoit je le
cite sous une autre forme incluant des
soins ambulatoires pouvant comporter des
soins à domicile pour que les choses
soient claires nous ne sommes pas
opposés à ce que les psychiatres des
établissement de santé considère compte
tenu de l'état de santé du patient que
celui-ci soit soigné en dehors d'une
structure hospitalière dans laquelle les
soins sont réalisés sous contrainte
l'internement aussi utile
soit-il doit demeurer l'exception à
l'inverse nous sommes contre le fait que
les patients qui subissent les manques
criants de moyens des établissement
psychiatriques et des établissements de
jour soit livrés à eux-mêmes ou de fête
placé sous la responsabilité de leurs
proches ceux qui nous interrogent du
point de vue du secret médical comme de
la responsabilité pénal éventuel qu'on
pourrait leur opposer c'est pourtant
bien ce que vous nous proposez avec cet
article de la même manière nous
contestons le fait qu'il reviennent au
Conseil d'État le soin d'établir des
protocoles nous considérons que la
médecine psychiatrique relève d'un
équilibre devant reposer à la fois sur
le respect de la volonté des patients
lorsqu'ils ont la capacité à la faire
valoir et la confiance en direction des
psychiatres et ce d'autant plus que la
procédure est encadrée même
imparfaitement par le juge des libertés
nous considérons que ces protocoles sont
des carcans qui enfermant les médecins
porteront atteintte aux intérêts des
patients raison pour laquelle nous y
sommes opposés pour toutes ces raisons
nous vous invitons à voter en faveur de
notre amendement de suppression de ces
deux alinéas merci mes chers collègues
amendement
88 Christiane de monè
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues l'alinéa 14 a trait aux soins
ambulatoires sans consentement et plus
spécifiquement à domicile actuellement
et contenu de la loi de 1990 la prise en
charge d'une personne sans son
consentement ne peut s'effectuer qu'au
travers d'une hospitalisation complète
dans les faites ces situations
représentent 21 à 22 % de l'ensemble des
hospitalisations j'observe d'ailleurs
que le rapport de l'itgas de 2005
recommandait de mettre fin à cette
solution univoque et de rechercher
d'autres modalités de prise en charge
sous contrainte l'hospitalisation devant
demeurer un cadre symbolique l'intérêt
du patient doit demeurer au centre de
nos préoccupations tout doit être mis en
œuvre pour que ces personnes bénéficient
des soins appropriés et nécessairire
afin qu'il puisse devenir de plus en
plus autonome et libre à cette fin et
quand l'état de santé de la personne le
permet nous pensons nécessaire que ces
soins soient effectués dans des
structures spécialisés avec des
professionnels compétents il ne s'agit
donc pas d'imposer des choix
thérapeutiques au psychiatres ces
derniers doivent conserver le choix de
l'outil thérapeutique qu'il juge le plus
approprié au regard de l'état clinique
du patient pour autant et compteenu de
l'existant privilégier la prise en
charge au sein des centres médicau
psychologique ou bien via une
hospitalisation de jour nous apparaît
comme participant de la nécessaire
recherche de l'amélioration de la santé
du patient mais aussi de la
reconnaissance du travail effectué dans
ces structures comportant des
psychiatres en effet ces espaces de
soins constiue le premier lieu de
référence et d'implantation des équipes
polyvalentes de secteor ces dernières
regroupent des médecins psychiatres des
psychologues cliniciens des infirmiers
des assistants sociaux des
psychomotriciens des orthophonistes des
éducateurs spécialisés unité de
coordination et d'accueil en milieu
ouvert elles organisent ces actions de
prévention de diagnostic de soins de
suivi ce sont des structures pivots qui
sont le plus à même d'élaborer les
stratégies thérapeutiques permettant de
réduire la durée d'hospitalisation et de
réinsérer la personne il s'agit donc
d'une alternative aux soins ambulatoires
d'ofice certes face au manque patant de
professionnels de CMP mais aussi de
place en hospitalisation de jour les
soins ambulatoires consacrent bien des
vertus comptable mais c'est avant tout
la santé de nos concitoyens et leur
amélioration et son amélioration que
nous devons favoriser en outre dans
l'étude d'impact figure le fait que le
soin ambulatoire comprend
essentiellement les prises en charge en
CMP qui demeure la structure pivot du
secteur merci amendement 260 la parole
est à Jean des Essards monsieur le
Président par cet amendement je vous
propose de supprimer l'alinéa 15 je vous
propose de supprimer la référence à ce
ce protocole de soins tout au long de ce
projet de loi cette défense vaut donc
pour tous les amendements de
coordination qui découlent de celui-ci
tous les psychiatres et les psychologues
que j'ai rencontré en amont de cette
discussion disent que leur cœur de
métier c'est la relation humaine tous
ces médecins redoutent une
médicalisation excessive de leur
profession l'établissement de ce
protocole de soins signifie la fin d'un
traitement individualisé et personnalisé
des patients ce protocole impliquerait
de définir les types de soins les lieux
de leur réalisation et leur périodicité
comme si la guérison était un processus
figé immuable qui s'établit dans des
conditions déterminées par décret en
Conseil d'État la relation entre le
soignant et le soigné ne peut dépendre
d'un tel protocole de la même façon que
l'obligation de soins sous contrainte
n'a aucun sens ce protocole est aux
antipodes de la façon de fonctionner des
équipe soignante depuis 5 ou 6 ans dans
certains hôpitaux ont été mis en place
des unit mobile ces petites unités
s'appuient sur l'entourage des malades
pour les convaincre de se soigner elle
travaille sur le consentement aux soins
grâce à l'établissement d'une relation
de confiance une fois la confiance
établie le soignant et le soigné élabor
un contrat thérapeutique le terme
contrat a toute son importance oui le
psychiatre et le patient peuvent se
mettre d'accord sur la marche à suivre
or le projet de loi parle de protocole
de soins comme s' était impossible de
avec les patients le médecin doit
impliquer le patient dans le soin sans
contrainte les malades mentaux peuvent
comprendre et dialoguer ce protocole de
soin n'est pas adapté à la réalité
clinique il faut du cas par cas et non
un protocole identique pour tous c'est
pourquoi je vous invite à supprimer
cette disposition qui méconnaît un
élément essentiel de la psychiatrie dans
un état de crise un patient doit pouvoir
faire confiance à ses soignants et en
tout état de cause c'est à travers un
véritable dialogue que doivent se
prendre les décisions de soins et non
contre la volonté du patient merci mon
cher collègue amendement 453 rectifié
qui le présente Jacques
mzard monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement numéro
453 nous proposons la suppression de
l'alinéa 15 en effet cette alinéa 15
précise que lorsque les soins
psychiatriques sans consentement
prennent la forme de soins
ambulatoire un protocole de soins est
établi qui définit les types de soins
les lieux de leur réalisation et leur
périodicité dans des conditions
déterminées par décret en Conseil d'État
or les prescriptions médicales relève
d'un contrat tacite entre le médecin et
son patient et se fonde sur les
principes du code de déontologie elle ne
saurait donc être contrainte par un
protocole dont le contenu serait
prédéfini par décret sur les types de
soins sur les lieux de leur réalisation
leur périodicité et qui serait transmis
et soumis aux interprétations des
autorités administrativ c'est pourquoi
nous proposons purement et simplement la
suppression de l'alinéa 15 merci
amendement
89 Claude jeen merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues l'amendement que que nous
proposons stipule que la Haute Autorité
de santé puisse être consulté avant la
prise de décret d'une certaine manière
mes chers collègues toute société n'a
que la psychiatrie qu'elle mérite or ce
projet de réforme n'est que la marque
d'une mutation anthropologique voulue
par ce gouvernement
assujettissement procédure légal sont
les maîtres mots de la démarche pourtant
le protocole de
soin reste un élément clé de ce projet
de loi mais en tant que tel il porte
toutes les contradictions de ses
inspirations la démarche thérapeutique
dans laquelle il est inscrit devrait
nous semble-t-il dépendre d'abord de
l'expertise de la Haute Autorité de
Santé pour que le décret du Conseil
d'État n'alimente pas la confusion entre
anomalie anormalité et illégalité la vie
préalable de la Haute Autorité de Santé
et c'est le sens de cet amendement
arrêtera les types de soins leur
périodicité et leur contenu en tenant
compte des recommandations admises par
la profession et non pas par les
injonctions de la dernière circulaire du
ministère de l'Intérieur le protocole
pourra par exemple chercher à préserver
toutes les chances d'insertion du malade
l'épidémiologie psychiatrique et la
sociologie ont pu démontrer que le
gradient social avait un rôle dans la
distribution de la plupart des troubl
mentaux d'où l'intérêt mes chers
collègues de cet appel à la Haute
Autorité de santé c'est pourquoi il nous
paraît préféraable que le décret en
Conseil d'État soit précédé de son avis
merci amendement numéro 6 jeenen le CF
monsieur le Président chers collègues
cet amendement numéro 6 tombera car il
sera satisfait en cas d'adoption du
sous-amendement numéro 490 rectifié de
notre collègue Lauren je ne dis pas de
du rapporteur cet amendement prévoyait
que la personne atteinte de troubles
mentaux devait être informée de son
droit de refuser les soins ambulatoires
et des conséquences qui s'attacheraient
à un tel refus c'est-à-dire une prise en
charge sous forme d'hospitalisation
complète cette précision paraît
importante à la commission des lois car
elle lui semble garantir la
constitutionnalité d'un recours qui
n'est que facultatif au juges
judiciaaires en matière de soins
ambulatoire sous contrainte en effet un
protocole de soins sans consentement n'a
pas vocation à conduire à l'exer d'une
contrainte physique à l'égard du patient
ce dernier pourrait décider de ne pas se
soumettre à ses obligations
thérapeutiques mais il encourrait alors
le risque d'une hospitalisation
complète merci amendement 90 Christian
deontè oui cet alinéa 15 de l'article 1
concerne l'édiction d'un protocole de
soins dans les cas où ils sont prodigués
en ambulatoire voire à domicile notons
que nous pouvons nous interroger sur la
dérogation au droit de tout malade de
consentir aux soins qu'il reçoit en
effet ce projet de loi ouvre un champ
inédit dans la mesure où la contrainte
pourra certes être exeré au sein d'un
établissement hospitalier mais aussi
hors de ces murs ce qui rend par essence
le contrôle de la nécessité et de la
proportionnalité des soins sans
consentement plus difficile autrement
dit la contrainte n'est plus seulement
inhérante au milieu hospitalier elle
s'exporte or par définition la
contrainte s'oppose au consentement
facteur pourtant essentiel à la réussite
des tra traitement thérapeutique relatif
à la maladie mentale par conséquent nous
pouvons légitimement nous demander si la
possibilité d'étendre les soins sans
consentement au régime ambulatoire y
compris à domicile est opportune d'un
point de vue sanitaire le protocole de
soins objet de cet alinéat établit les
types de soins les lieux de leur
réalisation et leur périodicité en somme
il définit la prescription des soins et
l'organisation de leur prise en charge
il convient d'y porter une attention
particulière car il conditionne le
succès du traitement et l'amélioration
de la santé du patient ainsi l'objectif
de notre amendement est de préciser que
le protocole de soin est révisable par
le psychiatre en effet l'évolution de la
maladie mentale nécessite une révision
du protocole de soin ne pas ouvrir cette
possibilité au psychiatre expose le
patient à des traitements inadaptés qui
peuvent conduire à une dégradation de
son état sanitaire de manière analogue
l'évolution de l'âge du malade peut
nécessiter de changer le protocole de
soin dans la mesure où certains
médicaments qui étaient auparavant
tolérés par l'organisme peuvent
représenter à un moment donné une menace
pour la santé du patient ainsi il
s'agirait d'une avancée majeure qui
bénéficierait aux victimes de troubles
mentaux et qui offrirait plus de
laattitude au psychiatre merci mon cher
collègue amendement 91 jaquy le
mè merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Madame le Ministre la
logique qui gouverne ce projet de loi
est l'enfermement avec deux facettes qui
se répond enfermé dedans enfermé dehors
dans le même temps il s'agit de
destituer les institutions existantes je
pense notamment où est le secteur et
dans une optique gestionnaire de
transférer l'hospitalisation du tir en
contention sanitaire à partir de là la
part de l'équipe soignante est niée et
réduite au soins délocalisés avec le
malade ce projet d'amendement propose un
retour vers le malade dans le respect de
sa personne et la prise en compte de sa
dimension d'être social attaché à un
cadre à une famille qui le connaît
peut-être à un travail et enfin qui sait
à un soignant avec qui aura tissé des
relations de confiance la fameuse
alliance thérapeutique pour que ces
dimensions fonctionnent dans l'intérêt
du patient il faut qu'il puisse être
mobile qu'il ait la possibilité de se
rapprocher d'un environnement social qu'
le reconnaisse lui et sa fragilité ce
qui est en cause ici ce n'est pas une
clause de cy mais de meilleures
conditions de réussite pour la clinique
c'est pourquoi nous proposons que le
protocole établisse les conditions
auxquelles le patient exercera sa
liberté de
résidence merci amendement
vous continuez monsieur le main tout à
fait madame le ministre il ne s'agit pas
avec cet amendement de donner au juges
le pouvoir de contrôler le contenu du
protocole de soins comme j'ai cru
l'entendre dans le cours de la
discussion précédent des précédentes le
juge n'est pas un médecin ça tout le
monde le sait cet amendement vise à lui
permettre de s'assurer que l'application
du protocole sera possible considérant
l'environnement social du malade sa
personnalité et la qualité des liens qui
l'unissent à ses proches nous pensons
ici particulièrement aux soins à
domicile devant le le cas de malade dont
les difficultés déborderont sur le
voisinage le maire pourra saisir le juge
des mesures correctrices nécessaires les
bailleurs sociaux savent la complexité
de ces situations et mesurent tous les
jours qu'elle ne se résolve pas ex
abrupto l'intervention du juge leur
apportera l'équilibre nécessaire en
permettant le retour à des formes plus
encadrées et plus outillées en compéten
médical tels sont les raisons pour
lesquelles nous proposons que le juge
puisse contrôler l'application des
protocole de soins quand il est prescrit
en
ambulatoire merci amendement 426 rtifbis
alin
Milon merci monsieur le Président si
l'amendement 280 était adopté il
faudrait dans l'AL 17 remplacer les mots
hospitalisation complète par les mots
hospitalisation temps plein c'est-à-dire
24h sur 24 et en conséquence procéder au
même remplacement sur l'ensemble du
texte vous l'avez compris c'est un
amendement de précision merci amendement
48 Labar
oui cet amendement vise à compléter
l'alinéa 17 relative à l'organisation de
la prise en charge des personnes
hospitalisées sans leur consentement il
prévoit que cette prise en charge donne
lie à une phase initiale d'observation
au cours de laquelle peuvent être
dispensés certains soins toutefois comme
chacun sait il est courant dans la
pratique que les patients fassent
faisant l'objet d'une hospitalisation
psychiatrique sans consentement soit
soumis au sédatif dès leur arrivée dans
les services hospitaliers d'ailleurs les
soins prodigués à l'occasion de cette
période d'observation sont souvent
lourds et de nature à anéantir les
facultés de discernement de ce dernier
mais alors comment mener à bien cette
phase d'observation initiale dont le but
présenter d'établir le bien fondé de
l'hospitalisation et de poser un
diagnostic si le patient est
complètement apathique bien souvent les
médecins se contenteront d'établir un
certificat médical au regard des
témoignages rapport portter souvent ceux
des forces de l'ordre dont la mission
principale est le respect de l'ordre
public d'ailleurs ces pratiques semblent
beaucoup plus courante qui n'y paraît
comme en témoigent certains patients qui
ont l'expérience des hospitalisations
sans consentement c'est donc pour
remédier à ces dysfonctionnements non
sans conséquence sur la situation des
personnes faisant l'objet des mesures
d'péalisation sans consentement que nous
souhaitons compléter l' Linéa 17 en
précisant notamment que sauf si elle
représente un danger pour elle-même la
personne admise ne pourra recevoir aucun
autre traitement médical haute que les
traitements somatiques si elle n'y a pas
consenti au préalable merci amendement
93 jequy
leomè merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre l'alinéa 17 du présent
article dispose qu'une personne admise
en soins sans consentement fait l'objet
d'une période d'observation et de soins
initial sous la forme d'une
hospitalisation complète au cours de
cette phase essentielle le malade reçoit
des soins somatiques si nécessaires et
est examiné par un psychiatre qui se
prononce sur la nécessité de maintenir
des les soins psychiatriques nouveuté
introduite par le projet de loi cette
période est capital en effet elle
conditionne l'éventuel futur traitement
du patient qui peut passer par une une
prorogation de la mesure
d'hospitalisation complète en ce cas la
liberté fondamentale du malade notamment
d'aller et venir sont fortement entravés
ainsi le égard aux conséquences sur
l'exercice de ces libertés cette phase
initiale doit être encadré dans le sens
d'une protection accrue des droits du
malade dans la mesureù nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une réf h parcellaire et
sécuritaire qui tend à traiter la
personne souffrant tout mentau comme un
des linquins nous souhaitons renforcer
les droits des patients pour les
préservé de tout préjudice et de tous
abus en d'autres termes cet amendement
entre dans une logique plus globale qui
vise à garantir à celles et à ceux qui
sont dans des situations d'extrême
fragilité par essence précaire le plein
exercice de leurs droit à cet égard ce
même raisonnement avait prévalu à la
rédaction de nos amendement pour le
raison projet de loi immigration qui
consacrait une approche tout aussi
sécuritaire entendonsnous ou bien
cependant l'objet de cet amendement
n'est aucunement de remettre en cause la
période d'observation et de soins qui
peut se révéler salvatrice pour la santé
du patient il est uniquement question de
l'aménager en vue d'une protection et
d'une application effective des droits
du malade c'est pourquoi nous proposons
de prévoir que le malade puisse faire
appel à un avocat dès la période
initiale d'observation et de soins la
présence d'un avocat est de nature à
assurer l'effectivité des droits du
patient et est d'autant plus nécessaire
et justifié que ce dernier est souvent
isolé coupé de sa famille et proche il
peut donc avoir besoin d'une réelle
assistance d'un véritable conseil pour
se défendre et faire valoir ses droits
d'où notre amendement merci amendement
49 il est présenté par Isabelle Pasquet
merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement est destiné à
garantir les droits des personnes
admises en soin psychiatri s sans
consentement dans un contexte où le juge
constitutionnel a clairement affirmer
que les soins psychiatriques
psychiatriques sans consentement étaient
assimilabl à des mesures privatives de
liberté il incombe au législateur de
tirer toutes les conséquences de cette
affirmation et ce notamment en
reconnaissant au patient faisant l'objet
de T mesure le bénéfice des droits de la
défense ainsi dans un premier temps nous
souhaitons reconnaître la possibilité
pour toute personne faisant l'objet de
soins psychiatriques sans consentement
de faire prévenir un proche et le droit
d'être assister d'un avocat si ces
droits apparaissent minimes au vu des
droits consacrés par l'article 5 de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et de ceux reconnu par la
jurisprudence de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen en
réalité il représenterait déjà une
avancée majeure dans le cadre de
l'hospitalisation psychiatrique sans
consentement n'oublions pas qu'à l'heure
actuelle et demain sans doute ces
derniers bénéficient malheureusement de
droit limités par rapport aux patients
classiques par ailleurs outre la
reconnaissance expresse des droits de la
défense pour ces personnes il comp
convient également d'informer ses
patients des droits dont il disposent en
effet pour pouvoir exercer ses droits
encore faut-il que le patient en est
connaissance c'est pourquoi notre
amendement précise que le patient parce
que il s'agit bien d'un patient dispose
de droit et notamment d'un droit à
l'information à la fois sur les soins
dispensés et sur les droits dont il
dispose au titre de sa prise en charge
d'ailleurs c cet amendement justifie
notre amendement précédent en ce sens
que le patient qui doit pouvoir
bénéficier d'une information sur ses
droits doit également être en état de
les comprendre ce que ne permet pas
l'injection de dose massive de calement
et de sédatif aux patients enfin
l'information n'est pas en tant que
telle suffisante elle doit
impérativement être adaptée à l'état du
patient aussi nous souhaitons par cet
amendement ajouter que le patient doit
être informé dans une langue qu'il
comprend et le cas échéant au moyen de
formulaire écrit Merci l'amendement 50
an
David pardon merci monsieur le Président
parfois il est bon d'invoquer le bon
sens et la logique au moment de
légiférer en espèce notre amendement
consiste à faire que le médecin chargé
de l'examen somatique de la personne
hospitalisée ne soit pas un médecin lié
à l'hôpital psychiatrique mais donc un
médecin extérieur à l'établissement
trois raisons simples et logiques à
cette proposition en premier lieu il est
nécessaire à notre avis d'éviter tout
risque de conflit d'intérêt en effet on
ne peut s'assurer formellement que le
psychiatre issu de l'établissement ne
subisse pas de pression avoué ou non
malheureusement nous savons que de tels
abus ont aujourd'hui court dans certains
établissements psychiatriques ensuite il
convient de prendre une telle
disposition parce que dans la pratique
cet examen somatique n'est quasiment non
jamais effectué en l'occurrence nous
pensons que l'intervention obligatoire
d'un médecin extérieur à l'hôpital
psychiatrique aura au moins pour
première conséquence positive de rendre
effective l'examen effectif pardon
l'examen somatique enfin il convient de
préciser que cet examen somatique ne
peut être effectué par un psychiatre qui
n'est pas forcément apte à déceler
certaines pathologies qui peuvent avoir
des conséquences psychiatriques c'est
trois raisons nous pousseent à proposer
cet amendement qui vise d'abord à lutter
contre le sentiment d'abandon que vivent
certains patients interné en hôpital
psychiatrique cela étant dit nous
considérons qu'une telle disposition ne
trouve son sens que si l'accompagnement
des patients est globalement amélioré en
effet la situation actuelle conséquence
de l'abandon par les pouvoirs publics de
la médecine psychiatrique a transformer
les hôpitaux psychiatriques
malheureusement en instruments à
interner et non à soigner si nous
déplorons la situation actuelle nous
devons également imaginer des solutions
pour répondre à vos aements c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous vous proposons
cet amendement qui permettra aux
patients de bénéficier réellement de cet
examen somatique pratiqué par un médecin
non
psychiatre merci amendement
454 rectifié Jacques
mard merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise d'une part
à
simplifier l'utilisation des certificats
médicaux et d'autre part à ramener le
délai d'observation de 72h à 48h comme
je l'ai déjà
exprimé tout à l'heure en défendant un
amendement précédent pas moins de six
certificats sont exigés dans la semaine
qui suit l'admission d'un patient voire
plus lorsqu'il s'agit de malade désigné
par l'exposé des motifs comme
potentiellement dangereux certes les
deux certificats médicaux à 24 et 72 he
et lorsque ces derniers ont conclu à la
nécessité de maintenir les soins l'avis
motivé proposant la forme de la prise en
charge peuvent sans doute être établi
par le même psychiatre sauf dans le cas
des personnes admises selon la procédure
ctière mais cela complique inutilement
la procédure et nous ne pensons pas que
ce soit pertinent dans un contexte
marqué par une insuffisance de moyens
d'évoluer aux établissements de santé et
avec la difficulté de recrutement des
spécialistes médicaux et infirmiers que
nous connaissons tous par ailleurs nous
sommes opposés à ce séjour obligatoire
de 72 he en hospitalisation complète qui
d'autres l'ont déjà dit à commencé par
les professionnels concernés s'apparent
à une garde à vue psychiatrique la
tentation sera forte de ne pas
s'interroger avant le terme du délai sur
le bien fondé de la contrainte nous
pensons que nous devons permettre à la
personne de sortir plus rapidement et
éventuellement de pouvoir bénéficier de
soins tout en réintégrant son domicile
nous proposons donc que lorsque le
certificat médical établi dans les 24
heures a conclu à la nécessité de
maintenir les soins psychiatriques un
psychiatre de l'établissement examine à
nouveau le patient dans les 48 Hees et
s'il conclut lui aussi à la nécessité de
maintenir ses soins propose dans un avis
motivé la forme de la prise en
charge merci amendement 94 Christiane
deess
oui monsieur le Président cette alinéa
de l'article 1 porte sur la période
initiale d'observation et de soins
nouvellement créés assimilé par de
nombreux praticiens qui nous l'ont dit à
une garde à vue psychiatrique durant
cette phase la personne admise en soin
psychi que sans consentement est prise
en charge sous la forme d'une
hospitalisation complète le premier
certificat médical est établi au terme
de 24 heur afin de confirmer ou
d'infirmer la nécessité de maintenir ses
soins après 72h un nouveau certificat
médical était dicté si les deux
certificats médicaux ont conclu à la
nécessité de maintenir les soins
psychiatriques sans consentement un
psychiatre de l'établissement d'accueil
propose la forme de la prise en charge
et rédige le cas échéant un protocole de
soins ainsi le délai de cette garde à
vue qui comprend certes un volet
sanitaire mais qui consacre surtout
l'orientation sécuritaire de ce projet
de loi est fixé à 72h au regard des
atteintes portées aux libertés publies
ce délai nous paraît excessivement long
songeons que durant cette période qui
doit être considéré comme un moyen de
guérir la personne admise en soins sans
consentement et non comme les prémisses
d'un traitement psychiatrique durable
fondé sur la contrainte le patient est
enfermé privé notamment de sa liberté
d'aller et venir pour cette raison nous
souhaitons réduire le délai de cette
phase initiale à 48 he plus protecteur
des libertés fondamentales en
particulier de la liberté individuelle
il ne serait pour autant aucunement un
frein au traitement thérapeutique du
patient par notre amendement l'équilibre
entre protection de la santé du patient
sauvegarde de ses libertés et
préservation de l'ordre public serait
davantage
respecté merci alors l'amendement 261 a
été défendu tout à l'heure si j'ai bien
compris
merci Monsieur Dessard c'est ce que vous
nous aviez dit tout à l'heure en
présentant le
260 bien nous avons eu la présentation
de ces 25 amendements monsieur le
rapporteur si vous pouvez nous donner la
position de la Commission sur ces 25
amendements merci monsieur le Président
en ce qui concerne le 45
rectifié la commission a émis un avis
favorable et les auteurs de l'amendement
entend donc s'opposer à l'instauration
des soins sans consentement en
ambulatoire à titre personnel j' Metet
un donc un avis
défavorable en ce qui concerne le 87 la
Commission a mis un avis favorable cet
amendement supprime les soins sans
consentement hors de l'hôpital vous
comprendrez bien que donc c'est l'avis
de la commission un avis défavorable à
titre personnel car il faut améliorer le
dispositif en ce qui concerne le
477 un avis de la commission est
défavorable il s'agit d'un changement de
terminologie qui en fait n'apporte pas
grand-chose dans ce cas notre collègue
madame paayet voit quelque chose de
péjoratif dans l'approche de de projet
ce de objet l'objet ne concerne pas le
malade mais la situation donc on ne vise
pas le malade c'est pourquoi euh je ne
retiens pas l'aspect péjoratif donc un
avis
défavorable euh monsieur le CF dans son
amendement numéro 5 et mon avis l'avis
global donc est favorable il s'agit
d'une précision qui est
bienvenue la commission des lois c'est
une de la
Commission en ce qui concerne le 46 la
Commission a mis un avis
favorable la question est pour nous de
pourquoi privilégier les CMP et les
hôpitaux de jour il existent d'autres
structures comme les centres d'accueil
thérapeutiques les appartements
thérapeutiques et cetera c'est pourquoi
cet aspect est beaucoup trop limitatif
et nous je pense que donc à titre
personnel j'ai met un avis
défavorable Monsieur Laurent alors le
280 est un amendement de monsieur mon la
Commission a mis un avis favorable cet
amendement vient préciser la notion de
soins sans consentement hors de
l'hôpital en visant des lieux plutôt que
des modes de prise en charge en faisant
référence à un programme de soins plutôt
qu'à un
protocole nous pensons que donc la
Commission a mis un avis favorable
personnellement je pense que c'est un
très bon
amendement de qui le sous-amendement
Laurin est-ce que la Commission a un
avis je prononce pas sur mon amendement
monsieur président non si si monsieur le
rapporteur vous donnez l'inv de la
Commission sur sous-amendement présenta
titre personnel donc nous savons que
Monsieur Lorin a présenté l'amendement
mais nous ne connaissons pas la position
du rapporteur de la commission c'est
pour ça que je vous demande de la
préciser défavorable la commission est
défavorable
la la commission est défavorable à mon
sousamendement et et et à titre
personnel moi je soutiens mon
amendement7 le 47 avis favorable de la
commission il s'agit d'un d'une
suppression donc à titre personnel
défavorable en ce qui concerne le 88 le
88 la position de la Commission est une
position favorable et je suis
personement à titre personnel
défavorable car qu'il n'y a pas de
raison de privilégier là aussi les CMP
et les hôpitaux de jour par rapport à
d'autres structures qui sont tout à fait
utiles
aussi si monsieur je l'ai dit je dit
j'ai été donné j'ai dit que la
commission a donné un avis
favorable
60 l'avis le le
60 c'est un amendement de suppression et
c'est un amendement de suppression vous
avez eu largement le temps de vous
exprimer sur la suppression je le pense
donc globalement la commission a donné
un avis favorable à cette
suppression c'est vous qui l'avez
exprimé dans
vos vous
continuez en ce qui concerne à titre
personnel j'apporterai un avis
défavorable et ça
continuera en ce qui concerne le
453 la commission a donné avis
défavorable parce queelle elle ne veut
pas elle supprime donc c alinéa et bien
à titre personnel je donnerai un avis
aussi
défavorable le rapporteur permettez-moi
de vous interrompre j'ai du mal à suivre
parce que la Commission elle a donné un
avis favorable au 260 et un avis
défavorable au
453 la commission a donné un avis
favorable au
que vous avez dit défavorable mais
c'était un lapsus c'est de façon à ce
que le compte-rendu retrace parfaitement
les positions de la Commission et celle
que me semble-t-il vous exprimez à titre
personnel bon continuez monsieur le
rapporteur merci non non ils arriveront
pas déstabiliser monsieur le Président
vous inquiétez
pas le
89 c'est un avis de la commission et de
l'ensemble de de des commissaires c'est
un avis favorable un avis de la ch ça
paraît
utile
voilà le 6 de la commission des lois en
ce qui concerne ce cet amendement la
Commission donne un avis favorable il
convient de laisser la discussion entre
le médecin et le patient se dérouler
sans introduire trop de rigidité c'est
le commentaire que je pourrais
faire c'est le 6 mais je dis favorable
90 avis favorable de la commission les
conditions de révision du protocole sont
évoquées dans l'amendement d'All Millon
et sous-amendé par le rapporteur qui
donne un avis défavorable à titre
personnel
1 91 la commission a donné un avis
favorable donc il ne convient pas de
rentrer dans tous les détails du
programme de soins c'est mon commentaire
et à titre personnel je donne un avis
défavorable
92 la Commission donne un avis favorable
il n'appartient pas au juge de se
prononcer sur le retour en
hospitalisation ou à sa prise en charge
dans un CMP c'est pourquoi à titre
personnel je donne un avis
défavorable
426tif
bis la commission a donné un avis
favorable et je suis donc favorable
aussi à titre
personnel
48 la commission a donné un avis
favorable mais cet amendement vise à
limiter les traitements sans
consentement au seuls soins somatiqu
c'est pourquoi à titre personnel
j'mettrai un avis
défavorable amendement 93
l'avis de la commission est un avis
favorable il s'agit de prévoir la
possibilité de se faire assister par un
avocat lors de la délivrance de
l'information donc pas titre personnel
je pense qu'il s'agit d'une formalité
trop lourde donc moi j'ai un avis
défavorable
49 cet avis de la commission est
favorable il s'agit de prévoir la
possibilité de se faire assister par un
avocat lors de la délivrance de
l'information à titre personnel j'ai met
un avis défavorable car il s'agit d'une
formalité trop
lourde amendement
50 la commission apporte un avis
favorable il s'agit donc de prévoir que
l'examen somatique réalisé au cours de
la période d'observation sera réalisé
par un médecin extérieur à
l'établissement à titre personnel j'ai
mon avis défavorable parce qu'il existe
des médecins généralistes assistants
dans les les
hôpitaux alors 454 rectifié 454 avis de
la commission favorable cet amendement
supprime le certificat prévu après 72 he
d'observation à titre personnel je pense
que ce certificat et au vu de l'ensemble
du texte que ce certificat est tout à
fait
utile donc de défavorable à titre
personnel
4 la commission a émis un
favorable la durée de 48 he serait trop
brève pour prendre les meilleures
décisions dans l'intérêt du patient donc
à titre personnel je suis
défavorable
la je sais pas ce qui
vous la commission a donné un avis
favorable les auteurs sont opposés à
l'idée d'un protocole de soin so or ce
programme de soins tel que nous l'avons
nommé nous-mêmes est donc utile donc à
titre personnel
défavorable
bien donc si je vous résume avec une
petite pointe d'humour tous les avis de
la commission sont favorables madame la
ministre monsieur le Président un
certain nombre d'amendements visés
les soins ambulatoires bien évidemment
vous imaginez que la viis est
défavorable sur tous ces amendements qui
dénaturent le le le fond du du texte qui
vous est proposé donc un avis
défavorable sur le
45 sur le 87
ensuite
alors j'ai un amendement de Madame
paayet pour lequel je suis défavorable
sur histoire de faisant l'objet plutôt
que recevant les soins
euh parce que ça ça complique ça
complique en effet la la question de de
de la sémantique qui nous obligerait à
qui pourrait entraîner des des oublis
dommageable en tout cas pour pour la
clarté des des bah des des termes
d'intitulé du chapitre alors un
amendement de précision auquel je suis
favorable 5 le 5 pardon euh le
l'amendement 46 euh qui propose
d'imposer des soins euh soit en CMP soit
en hôpital de jour euh bien évidemment
la démarche de prise en charge en tout
cas à l'extérieur de l'hôpital ne peut
pas être inscrite dans la loi et c'est
bien le médecin qui décide en fonction
des du besoin de du malade euh les
modalités euh qui sont les plus adaptées
pour encadrer le patient donc un avis
défavorable au numéro 46 euh j'en arrive
à l'amendement 280 de Monsieur million
je
voudrais dire que c'est un excellent
amendement je voudrais remercier euh le
sénateur Milon parce que quelque part il
vient apaiser toutes les craintes qui
sont qui ont pu être émises d'ailleurs
par euh emble des groupes puisqu'il
vient préciser les outils thérapeutiques
de la psychiatrie qui soit qui sont
adaptés euh à l'état du malade et il
effectivement différencie des unités
d'hospitalisation avec des unités
alternatives et la palette d'offre de
soins possies alternativ à
l'hospitalisation donc euh c'est quelque
chose qui apporte de la clarté en tout
cas ce qui a été attendu par l'ensemble
des euh de cette Haute Assemblée euh et
puis y a une question qui est
intéressante enfin une précision
intéressante c'est la question du
programme de soin je crois que là aussi
c'est
une quelque chose qui peut paraître un
détail sémantique mais qui a tout son
sens pourquoi parce que je crois que le
terme de protocole de soin a davantage
créé de la confusion dans l'esprit d'un
grand nombre de de personnes parce que
qui dit protoc de soins il y a eu une
association d'idée un peu automatique
avec protocole
thérapeutique on n'est pas forcément
dans une prise en charge
médicamenteuse et c'est pourquoi
finalement modifier protocole par
programme est beaucoup plus extensif en
tout cas dans dans le sens sout-endu par
par ce terme donc il peut s'agè
effectivement de prise en charge
thérapeutique mais évidemment toutes les
autres alternatives de prise en charge à
l'hospitalisation donc un avis très
favorable à l'amendement Milon et
s'agissant du sous-amendement par
Monsieur
Laurin il apporte lui aussi des
précisions donc un amendement pour
lequel je suis extrêmement favorable
puisque il complète l'amendement du
sénateur Milon
euh avec des des précision aussi qui
vise à à apaiser finalement et à
répondre à un certain nombre de vos
attentes puisque qu'il il permet de de
mettre en place en tout cas d'entériner
la la notion de
l'entretien au cours duquel le
psychiatre délivre de l'information de
l'information à son patient qui tente de
recueillir son avis il réitère la notion
de respect du secret médical et puis
il permet de de de mettre en place en
tout cas la la pertinence du traitement
en tout en tout cas de la prise en
charge du du malade sans pour autant
dévoiler la le détail de de la prise en
charge médicamenteuse qui est là laissé
bien sûr à la liberté du du psychiatre
du médecin qui est lui le thérapeute
c'est comme le programme de soins
finalement c'est comme une ordonnance
l'ordonnance on prévoit ce qu'on y met
qui écrit et qu'est-ce qu'on prévoit la
date le nom du
malade les médicaments avec la posologie
la durée de de traitement mais on ne
précise pas évidemment les médicaments
euh et toute la démarche thérapeutique
qui est bien sûr décidée par par le
thérapeute le médecin donc un avis euh
très favorable à ces deux amendements
alors vous comprenez bien que en étant
favorable à ces deux amendements il y a
un certain nombre d'amendements qui euh
euh qui euh finalement ne ne sont
apparaissent un peu dénués justement de
leurs substan à partir du moment où cela
apporte des clarifications euh
défavorable comme attendu pour
l'amendement 47
euh puisque il supprime les soins
ambulatoires euh l'amendement
88 qui rejoint finalement l'amendement
précédent sur l'hôpital de jour et les
CMP des hôpitaux de jour là aussi ce
détail est laissé à la liberté du
psychiatre qui décide lui-même de la
démarche la plus adaptée aux patients
donc un avis défavorable ce n'est pas
une question à à imposer dans la
loi l'amendement
260 euh alors
celui-ci un avis défavorable bien
entendu il s'agit de de mettre dans la
loi la procédure de de protocole de soin
alors oui j'ai été un petit peu ça m'a
interpellé de de lire protocole de soins
préformaté de vous entendre aussi
préformaté et standardisé je vi vient de
m'exprimer sur la question du programme
de soins en aucun cas la loi en tout cas
la la décision thérapeutique incombe au
législateur ou à un quelconque acteur en
tout cas si ce n'est au médecin lui-même
qui décide de la meilleure prise en
charge
possible qui dépend évidemment de l'état
de santé du du patient donc en aucun cas
un protocole de soins c'est pour ça que
le terme de programme de soins est plus
approprié parce que protocole je le
disais tout à l'heure on fait un peu
l'idée avec le médicament qui est pas du
tout le ce qui est ciblé dans dans le
dans la loi donc en aucun cas un
protocole qui serait préformaté ou
standardisé bah un programme mais celui
qui décide du programme c'est quand même
le psychiatre c'est lui qui décide de la
prise en charge la plus adaptée au
patient en fonction de son état de santé
c'est pas au législateur de dire ce
qu'il faut enfin il y a pas une
ordonnance type qui soit superposable à
l'ensemble des malades enfin moi qui
suis médecin j'ai j'aurais pas aimé
qu'on m'impose l'ordonnance que j'ai à
prescrire voilà ensuite nous avons
l'amendement
453 là aussi nous sommes dans une
suppression du protocole de soins donc
avis
défavorable euh nous avons
ensuite le décret au Conseil d'État pour
euh qui doit être soumis à l'avis de la
Haute Autorité de Santé un avis
défavorable parce
que parce que
objectivement il n'y a pas
de objectivement il y a on n pas le
temps d'avoir l'avis de l'achas avant le
le décret en Conseil d'État donc c'est
quelque chose qui euh euh qui n
objectivement n'est pas ne peut pas être
honoré en tant que tel donc un avis
défavorable l'amendement je c'est le
numéro 6
après pardon ben c'est comme
ça l'amendement numéro 6 droit de
refuser les soins monsieur le SER je
crois que un malade qui n'est pas
capable
de
de qui n'est pas conscient de son état
de santé malheureusement n'est pas
capable ni d'accepter ou de refuser son
protocole ou enfin en tout cas les soins
qui lui sont proposés euh dans la mesure
où il est pas capable de consentir donc
c'est un avis
euh une demande de retrait de
l'amendement si ce n'est pas un retrait
ça serait un avis défavorable du
gouvernement
ensuite nous avons l'amendement
le protocole de so madame de montais je
crois que c'est vous qui l'avez présenté
le protocole peut-être modifié par le
psychiatre je crois que c'est une
évidence à tout moment le
psychiatre en fonction l'état de santé
de son patient oriente amende adapte le
protocole de soins donc c'est quelque
chose qui me paraît satisfait d'ailleurs
qui est intégré dans les bonnes pratique
donc c'est un avis
défavorable l'amendement
qui est un un avis défavorable du
gouvernement
euh défavorable parce qu'il est sans
objet avec le programme de
soins l'amendement
92 c'est un avis défavorable du
gouvernement le juge des libertés et la
détention n'a pas à se prononcer sur la
faisabilité du du programme de soins on
n'est pas dans une privation d'aller y
venir enfin de de liberté d'aller et
venir et c'est pas ce qui est prévu en
tout cas par le Conseil
constitutionnel l'amendement
426 euh c'est un amendement de précision
avis favorable
euh l'amendement
48 là nous sommes euh ah oui c'est euh
c'est se contenter de soins somatiques
euh si le le
patient s'y oppose c'est ça donc c'est
un avis défavorable
euh non non un avis
défavorable c'est un avis défavorable
malheureusement on est bien dans c'est
un avis défvorable
non défavorable bien entendu si le
patient nécessite enfin est admis pour
des soins sans consentement il les par
définition c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure par définition il ne peut ni
consentir ni refuser des
soins alors
c'est il peut pas s'opposer s'il
est mais moi je crois qu'il faut faire
confiance au psychiatre et qui sont les
à même de
décider en tout cas la meilleure
approche thérapeutique et de prise en
charge pour leurs malades je j'ai je
suis plus encline à faire confiance au
psychiatre que de légiférer sur ce que
les psychiatres ont à
faire nous avons l'amendement
93 alors faire appel à l'avocat je crois
que c'est de l'ordre du droit commun
donc pour moi c'est un une en tout cas
une demande qui est
satisfaite donc avis
défavorable amendement
49 euh
c'est alors là
euh c'est un amendement qui est
finalement déjà satisfait par par la loi
là aussi c'est la question de demander à
un avocat
euh l'intervention de de
l'avocat en début de d'hospitalisation
c'est l'article L 321 3 du Code de la
santé publique donc le droit
commun l'examen alors amendement 50 qui
concerne l'examen somatique
euh c'était
voilà vous prévoyez un examen somatique
à l'extérieur là de la même manière je
pense que les médecins qui accueillent
les patients sont à même de prodiguer un
examen clinique et de pouvoir détecter
les éventuelles anomalies euh euh
somatiques donc là aussi c'est une
question de je préfère faire confiance
au aux médecins qui accueillent les les
malades donc c'est un avis défavorable
oui mais ils sont médecins enfin ils ont
une formation de médecins somaticien à
la base euh l'amendement
454 réduire la période d'observation euh
à 48h euh bah c'est une novation aussi
dans le texte donc vous comprenez que je
suis défavorable à cet amendement mais
c'est un avis défavorable parce que euh
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on met une
période d'observation de 72 he que le
malade n'est pas enfin n'est pas apte à
sortir avant si son état le permet le
psychiatre peut tout à fait décider que
au vu de 48 heures d'observation il peut
décider au vu de l'état de santé du
malade de le faire sortir avant les 72
he de observation je crois que l'intérêt
dans la journée supplémentaire
d'observation c'est vraiment d'essayer
de d'avoir cette alliance thérapeutique
d'avoir le le consentement du malade
dans le le programme qui va lui être
proposé donc ce n'est pas un délai
incompressible c'est bien une chance
supplémentaire pour le malade d'adhérer
et d'adhérer à à à son protocole de soin
donc c'est un avis
défavorable amendement 94 je crois que
nous sommes dans la même disposition
donc avis
défavorable l'amendement
261 amendement euh défavorable voilà je
crois que j'ai merci Madame la
Ministre
alors on va passer au vote j'ai vu j'ai
vu les mains de Jean-Pierre Michel et
d'Alain Milon se lever jacanc mais euh
on n'est plus dans le débat donc on va
appeler les amendements et si ces
demandes sont des demandes d'explication
de vote je ne sais pas à quels
amendements encore il s'applique mais je
ne vais pas tarder à le savoir puisque
hein alors rappel au règlement alors
rappel au règlement à la Milon à la
parole pas un rappel au
règlement monsieur non plus
oui monsieur le Président c'est un petit
rappel au règlement je dis dire que j'ai
été extrêmement surpris étonné et peiné
de par l'attitude de de deux de nos nos
amis sénateurs vis-à-vis de monsieur le
rapporteur c'estàdire monsieur de cessar
et Monsieur Michel je trouve leur
attitude assez inconvenante par rapport
à monsieur le rapporteur qui a repris le
le rapport simplement vendredi qui est
donc en train de se battre sur un texte
qu'il a qu'il a dû prendre dont il a dû
prendre connaissance à partir de
vendredi j'ai entendu dans votre bouche
Monsieur Michel les mots de maladie
mentale ou de schizophrénie j'espère qui
ne s'adressait pas à monsieur le
rapporteur mais je voudrais vous
rappeler l'évolution du texte dans le
cadre de la commission des affaires
sociales la le le premier les premiers
amendements qui ont été présentés par
madame la Présidente ont été votés au
tout début par madame la Présidente par
deux sénatrices de du centre madame
madame lettard et Madame CW par deux
sénateurs de l'UMP madame camerman et
moi-même et par la gauche et au bout du
compte quand l'ensemble du texte est
arrivé à la fin c'est la gauche qui n'a
pas voté le texte et au bout du compte
madame la rapporteur présidente s'est
retrouvé sans texte et monsieur le
rapporteur est arrivé ensuite alors ayez
un peu de respect pour le travail qu'il
joue il joue au Pompi actuellement il le
fait bien et moi j'approuve ce qu'il est
en train de
faire vous fondiez votre rappel en
rlement sur l'article qui concerne le
fonctionnement des commissions et bien
ce qui m'avait
semblé rappelle au règlement Monsieur
Michel que bon puisque on est dans la
fantaisie la plus totale
continuons tout d'abord je voudrais dire
que nous sommes dans une séance
absolument
ubuesque monsieur Laurin votre avis
personnel ne nous intéresse
pas si vous voulez le donner vous allez
à votre band des sénateurs et vous le
donnerez comme tous les autres sénateurs
ici au moment des explications de vote
vous êtes rapporteur d'une commission
vous devez respecter les votes de cette
commission
PL si ça continue comme ça le groupe
auquel j'appartiens quittera la séance
et ne participera plus à ces débats à
quoi
sert-il d'avoir une commission de voter
en commission vous étiez minoritaire
prenez-vousen à vos
amis alors bien sûr que c'est
schizophrène de dire la Commission est
pour l'amendement à personnel je suis
contre la commission était contre
l'amendementtre personnel je suis pour
voilà ce qu'on a entendu cette situation
est absolument intolérable il est temps
qu'elle cesse où nous ne participerons
plus à la discussion je le dis très
clairement bien oui oui oui il y en aura
pour tout le monde prenez votre temps
Monsieur Michel se fondit sur le même
article que Monsieur Milon alors j'ai vu
il s'agit-il de rappel au règlement
alors vous me dites sur quel article
pour qu'on arrête et qu'on soit vraiment
dans des app au règlement et non pas
dans la voocation d'état d'âme qui a 23
he
15 sont tout à fait intéressants que
j'apprécie beaucoup mais il ne nous
reste à cette heure que
15 articles donc je dire amendement il y
a moins d'articles rassurons-nous donc
j'ai vu madame David monsieur Desessard
madame Judit Chelly monsieur blanc qui
m'ont fait tous les qu des demandes de
rappel au règlement alors je leur
demanderai de respecter strictement
notre règlement
oui je vous remercie monsieur le
Président et effectivement ce sera un
rappel au Règlement sur le
fonctionnement de notre commission
puisque notre collègue al la Milon
impute la faute à la gauche sur le
nonvote du texte de la commission je
trouve là pour le coup mon cher collègue
que vous êtes un peu dans l'exagération
car ce que nous votons ce soir les
amendements dont nous débattons ce soir
ce sont les amendements que nous avons
vu ce matin à la commission la
commission ce matin des affaires
sociales s'est réunie et oui les
sénateurs de gauche étaient majoritaires
pendant le temps de cette commission
donc ce matin pendant la Commission les
sénatrices et sénateurs de gauche ont
majoritairement donner un avis favorable
à ces amendements donc la commission a
émis un avis favorable à ses amendements
et Monsieur Laurin s'il n'a pris ce
texte en main que vendredi je le
regrette bien pour lui mais ça fait déjà
un petit moment mon chers collègues et
vous le savez bien car vous avez assisté
plus que ce que je n'ai pu le faire à
mon grand regret à l'ensemble des des
travaux de la commission ça fait quand
même déjà plusieurs semaines que la
Commission travaille sur ce texte madame
mugadini qui était rapporteur auparavant
a fait un grand nombre d'auditions
ouvertees à l'ensemble des sénatrices et
des sénateurs de la commission si
Monsieur Laurin n'a pris connaissance du
texte que vendredi je ne peux que le
regretter pour lui car effectivement
c'est un texte très complexe très
compliqué c'est ce que Monsieur c'est ce
que Monsieur Milon nous a dit que vous
avez repris le texte vendredi donc je je
sais bien monsieur Laurin mais monsieur
Milan nous dit qu'il faut respecter
votre travail de ce soir car vous n'avez
repris ce texte que vendredi c'est bien
regrettable d'avoir ce genre d'échange
ici mon cher collègue car nous avons
fait ce que nous avions à faire en
commission chacun de nous a fait ce qui
lui a semblé bon de faire au moment de
la commission ici mercredi dernier le
texte de la commission n'a pas
été adopté vous ne pouvez quand même pas
en reporter la faute sur les Sénat et
sénateur de gauche qui étaient présents
à ce moment-là comme ils étaient encore
présents ce matin à la Commission et
comme ils sont présents ce soir au cours
des débats donc la Commission a fait ce
qu'elle avait à faire mais il est vrai
qu'il serait quand même beaucoup plus
agréable pour les sénatrices et sénateur
que nous sommes d'avoir l'avis de la
commission ensuite si Monsieur Laurin en
tant que sénateur de la Commission veut
donner son avis et bien qu'il le fasse
depuis les bancs de l'UMP puisqueà ce
moment-là son av vie n'est que la vie
d'un sénateur du groupe UMP au même
titre que laave que vous pourriez donner
les uns et les autres les unes et les
autres ce soir donc ce que nous voulons
entendre du ban de la commission c'est
l'avis du rapporteur c'est c'est comme
ça en tout cas que cela se passe
habituellement merci Jean Desessard pour
Rael au règlement
oui monsieur Milon vous faites un
mauvais procès parce que si j'avais été
à la commission jusqu'à la fin de la
commission j'aurais voté le texte et
parce que effectivement on aurait eu un
texte différent aujourd'hui présenté
mais là mes remarques vis-à-vis du
rapporteur portaient pas sur ce pointlà
et vous nous vous faites référence à ce
point mais porte sur le fait que ce
matin les sénateurs de de droite comme
ça a été dit si on peut vous classer
comme ça
ENF le MP était pas
présent et donc pendant 2h on débat et
on vote donc normalement c'est
institutionnellement la position de la
Commission n pour Moen nous on on va pas
sortir on vient on est là on va pas dire
on part pour qu'il y ait davantage de
personnes de droite par rapport à la
gauche donc on vote c'est donc la
position de la Commission donc c'est
particulièrement désagréable d'avoir
perdu 2h ce matin d'avoir pris le temps
de voter c'est donc
institutionnement
institutionnellement la position de la
Commission et on s'aperçoit que le
rapporteur et ben n'en tient pas compte
se sent euh inspiré de façon divine en
disant moi personnellement j'exprime la
position du Sénat mais qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça il réinvente la démocratie
puisque la démocratie c'est la
commission ce matin qui décide donc
c'est à il doit donner le point de vue
de la commission qu'il n'en fasse pas
trop et qu'il n'en fasse pas des kilos
d'accord mais il n pas obligé de nier le
travail de la commission de ce matin de
nier des personnes qui sont déplacées et
s'il y a une responsabilité et bien
c'est l'absence des sénateurs r MP ce
matin en commission madameud Chell pour
rappel au
règlement si vous le permettez monsieur
le Président c'est pas un rappel au
règlement c'est une question que
j'aimerais vous poser à vous qui
présidez cette commission ce qui se
passe ce soir Madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales peut en
témoigner m'est arrivé et le directeur
de la séance également pour le un
rapport sur la transposition des
directive européenne euh ce qui s'est
passé avec la la commission dont madame
la Présidente était rapporteur la en
grand en majorité puisque nous n'étions
pas majoritaires à l'UMP tous les
amendements sont passés puis au moment à
la fin de voter au moment où il
s'agissait de voter le texte nous nous
avons dit nous ne le non on peut pas le
voter ainsi modifié et les les les
autres sénateurs qui avaient voté tous
les amendements ont dit on ne ve pas de
texte et nous nous retrouvons sans texte
et cetera et vous connaissez la suite
lorsque Madame dy était à côté de moi au
moment de la transposition des
directives européennes il s'était passé
à peu près la même chose et et moi je
continuais à dire et Monsieur ficher
peut en témoigner puisque lui aussi
n'était pas content ce soir-là et je le
comprenais je disais la commission parce
que personne ne voulait voter la les la
transposition des directives européennes
et j'étais seul en commission a voté
pour pour une simple raison monsieur le
Président on savait bien que si nous ne
votions pas ça qu'on nous demandait de
répondre à des questions qu'on ne nous
avait pas posé il y aurait quelques
dizaines de millions d'euros que la
France avant le 30 mai je crois aurait
auraittu à payer donc j'ai je me
contentais simplement de dire voilà ce
qui s'est passé moi titre personnel ce
que dit Monsieur Laurin depuis le début
de la soirée a-t-il avis favorable de la
commission mais à titre personnel avis
défavorable sur tel amendement je crois
que madame le ministre était déjà là
alors je voudrais savoir parce que
est-ce qu'il était est-ce qu'il est
légal ou pas de dire dans un contexte
très particulier comme ça s'est déjà
produit et comme ça se produit ce soir
et heureusement que la présidente de la
commission est à côté de moi parce qu'à
votre place il y avait un autre
président qui à un moment quand même
osit me dire si vous voulez donner votre
avis personnel vous n'êtes plus
rapporteur et j'ai dit dit non monsieur
le Président je suis pas d'accord alors
je voudrais qu'une fois pour toutes on
ne mette pas les sénateurs dans ce genre
de position la tous les les les
sénateurs de gauche et vous êtes tous
témoins ont voté tous les amendements
qu'a proposé madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales et au
moment d'adopter le texte on dit non on
ne le vote pas comme nous nous n'avons
rien voté on l'a pas voté on se retrouve
sans texte je voudrais simplement
puisque je n'ai pas une expérience de 20
ans de sénateur savoir quel est votre
avis ce qu'il est légal de faire ce
qu'il n'est pas possible et cetera et
cetera pour ça que ce n'était pas un
rappel au règlement mais ça me semblait
important bien madame je vous remercie
de vouloir me simplifier la vie en me
rendant en me rendant juge ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que ce qui
caractérise un parlement c'est que la
parole est libre et que le vote est
libre et que les commissions
s'organisent et votent et que le vote
sur un amendement est libre et que le
vote sur le texte global est libre alors
c'est vrai que nousous trouvons ce soir
dans une situation un petit peu
particulière puisque mais qui ne tient
pas si vous me permettez au fait que la
Commission n'est pas adopté de texte
parce que la Commission n n'adopte pas
de texte il reste un texte c'est celui
qui vient de l'Assemblé nationale et la
séance de ce matin était une séance où
les amendements texte de la commission
de sortie de l'Assemblée nationale
pardon était présenté la situation un
peu particulière que nous vivons ce soir
tient au fait que la Commission a pris
ce matin dans sa majorité de commission
des positions qui ne correspondent pas
si j'ai un peu compris ce qui se passait
qui ne correspondent pas à la position
qui s'exprime majoritairement ce soir il
n'en reste pas moins que nos règles
internes et le règlement fait que le
rôle du rapporteur de la commission est
de donner l'avis de la commission et de
dire pourquoi la Commission a pris cet
avis et qu'après je dirais à titre
personnel ils disent je crois que dans
l'exemple auquel vous faisz allusion la
Commission avait pris des position qui
ne correspondait pas à ce que vous
vouliez en tant que rapporteur et donc
vousez la Commission a pris ça mais moi
j'étais pas d'accord c'est différent
mais vous valorisiez la position de la
Commission et je pense que s'il y a une
situation un peu particulière ce soir
bon dont nous à laquelle nous survivrons
tous hein rassurez-vous s'il y a une
situation un peu particulière ce soir ça
tient au fait que
effectivement les gens qui étaient
majoritaires peuvent estimer que les
avis de la commission et les éléments
favorables ne sont peut-être pas
argumentés de manière suffisante mais là
vous allez m'obliger à sortir de mon
rôle de président ce dont je me garderai
bien quant à ma position personnelle
c'est que le président ne prend pas part
au vote ce qui lui permet de penser
néanmoins ce qu'il veut tout en
regardant avec beaucoup d'intérêt les
débats voilà mais effectivement ça vient
de la monsieur blanc dernier appel au
règlement et en me promettant de ne pas
me poser de questions pas de question
mais un rappel que je pense il est
peut-être nécessaire de faire puisque
qu'il s'agit de quoi ce soir il s'agit
pas de protéger la
société il s'agit de
protéger des personnes atteintes d'une
maladie psychiatrique et que cette
maladie fait
justement que le malade n'a pas
conscience de sa maladie par exemple
dans un délire et que nous sommes et que
nous sommes en face d'une situation
l'intérêt du malade et je mets l'intérêt
mal rappel au règlement on est sur
rappelle au règlement et je vais y venir
monsieur le Président l'intérê l'intérêt
du malade exige que l'on trouve des
réponses adaptées pour lui permettre de
sortir de sa maladie et donc de lui
imposer des soins et mon rappel au
règlement c'est que nous avons la
chance que la Commission qui a fait un
travail difficile parce parce que c'est
un sujet complexe a quand même donné des
avis qui rejoignent les sentiments du
rapporteurs ses sentiments personnels
sur l'amendement de Monsieur Millon et
il me semble qu'on pourrait tous se
retrouver autour de cet amendement
montrer que le Sénat fait avancer les
choses et donc dans mon rappel au
règlement je demandais monsieur le
Président ce n'est pas possible de
mettre aux voix l'amendement de Monsieur
Millon
qui a l'approbation du gouvernement
l'approbation du rapporteur et je pense
ce qui peut être approuvé par les uns et
par les autres parce qu'il répond
vraiment à une interrogation que l'on
doit avoir chacun comment permettre à
ces malades de sortir de cette maladie
d'être bien pris en charge et d'avoir
une sécurité d'un programme qui serait
élaboré et donc peut-être qu'on pourrait
monsieur le Président montrer
que dans ce débat un peu difficile le
Sénat apporte une contribution très
positive pour répondre à un sujet
difficile et aller de l'avant merci bien
alors je vous remercie je vous remercie
de ces rappel au règlement don je vous
laisserai chacun personnement juge de
l'étroitesse avec laquelle il concne un
règlement et je vais maintenant arriver
à l'amendement 45 et 87 qui sont deux
amendements identiques pour lesquels
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public pour l'un par le groupe
socialiste pour l'autre par le groupe
CRC je vous ai vu monsieur le Président
et donc nous
allons écouter sur ces deux amendements
puisqu'il n'y aura qu'un vote les
explications de vote s'il y en a alors
explication de vote de Monsieur ficher
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis
monsieur Michel puis d'autres sil leent
monsieur le Président ficher oui donc
naturellement les sénateurs de notre
groupe voteront en faveur de ces deux
amendements bien sûr et là je voudrais
plus
particulièrement m'exliquer par rapport
au
87 puisque c'est celui-ci dont il s'agit
qui a par ailleurs et à deux reprises
reçu un avis favorable de la commission
des affaires sociales qui vise à
supprimer les soins sans consentement en
ambulatoire alors cette proposition
récurrente présenté comme devant
permettre une
diversification des modalités de soins
face à l'hospitalisation
complète constitue je le répète une
nouvelle fois une mauvaise réponse à une
bonne question si nous ne doutons pas
que l'hospitalisation complète puisse
être inappr prier pour certains patients
nous ne croyons pas que l'extension de
la contrainte au domicile du patient qui
peut-être celui des patients ou de la
famille soit pour autant une bonne
mesure cette diversité nécessaire à la
bonne prise en charge de tous les
patients doit d'abord et avant tout
reposer sur une politique de secteur qui
puisse être capable de répondre
quotidiennement aux attentes des
personnes atteintes de maladie mental
tout comme comm au périodes de crise
lorsqu'elles surviennent et convenez
qu'en l'état actuel des moyens dédiés à
la psychiatrie et au secteur en
particulier nous en sommes loin il y a
un véritable fossé entre la théorie et
la pratique et le seul mode diversifié
que vous prononcez tant à favoriser le
tout médicament sur le processus
psychanalytique évidemment nécessaire
mais par ailleurs et cela n'est pas sans
lien avec ce dont nous venons de parler
nous avons appris ce matin à l'occasion
d'une table ronde que nous organisions
avec des représentants des
professionnels de la psychiatrie et des
représentants de patients ou anciens
patients nous avons appris que dans plus
de plus en plus de villes les
consultations psychiatriques au sein des
centres médicaux-psychiatriques étaient
devenu
payant jusqu'alors ils étaient ces
consultations étaient gratuites et cette
gratuité permettait à tous les patient
en souffrance de venir parler et par
voie de conséquen de désamorcer
d'éventuelles crises et dans ma ville
j'ai un centre de thérapie brève qui
jouait et joue un rôle important les
rentes payantes c'est prendre le risque
que ces publics qui sont très souvent
démunis du point de vue financier
désertent ces consultations et qu'ell ne
soit plus traité demain qu'à l'occasion
des périodes de crise donc nous en
revenons à notre critique principale de
votre conception de la psychiatrie une
conception sécuritaire destinée à faire
cesser les crise et les troubles et non
soigner les patients et jusqu'au bout de
ce débat et bien
nous continuerons dans cette critique je
crois mes chers collègues qu'il aurait
été souhaitable que le gouvernement
s'entienne à la stricte décision du
Conseil constitutionnel et qu'on aille
pas plus loin c'est-à-dire en la
limitant à un article prévoyant
l'intervention du juge des libertés cela
nous aurait évité d'aborder les la
question des formes de soin en dehors
d'une loi plus large relative à la
psychiatrie dans son ensemble alors donc
nous voterons cette amendement
considérant que la suppression des soins
sans consentement en ambulatoire
présenterait l'avantage de supprimer le
dispositif le plus décrié par les
professionnels concernés comme par les
patient
merci pour explication notre la parole
l'ét Jen leerf rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des lois oui monsieur le
Président je je ne voterai pas les
amendements 87 et 45 car il me semble
que les soins ambulatoires sous
contrainte à condition et c'est une
condition importante à condition qu'il
fasse bien diminuer le nombre des
hospitalisations sans consentement et ne
viennent pas s'ajouter à celle-ci mérite
d'être approuvé mérite d'être approuvé
dès lors qu'il constitue une alternative
à l'hospitalisation complète et donc une
alternative à une mesure privative de
liberté dès lors en outre que cette
alternative à l'enfermement est entourée
de garantie en particulier lorsqu'elle
prend la forme d'une hospitalisation
partielle et je vous voulais faire
observer que c'est précisément ce qu'a
voulu la Commission des loi en adoptant
un amendement instaurant un contrôle
systématique du juge en cas
d'hospitalisation partielle à compter du
1er septembre
2012 merci Jean-Pierre
Michel merci Monsieur le prés Président
je voudrais rappeler d'abord que ces
deux amendements identiques ont été
approuvés deux fois par la commission
des affaires sociales la semaine
dernière et ce
matin nen déplaise à Monsieur Laurin je
ve pas dire au rapporteur puisque il ne
rapporte pas ce que la Commission a fait
alors dans la proposition de loi que
j'avais rapporté ici signée par mon
collègue jean-ren leer Christian demmont
et Gilbert Barbier il est il était prévu
des soins sous contrainte obligatoire
ambulatoire mais dans le cas de malad
mentaux délinquant qui sortaiit de
prison disons plus rapidement plus vite
et pour lesquels on imposait comme une
des conditions du contrôle judiciaire je
vais dire une obligation de soin ça ça
ça nous paraissait cohérent d'ailleurs
le Sénat a voté à l'unanimité contre la
VI du gouvernement cette proposition de
loi ça nous paraissait cohérent parce
que bien sûr comme l'a dit jeonf à
l'instant c'était une alternative à
l'enfermement et à l'emprisonnement et
ça avait une sanction c'est-à-dire que
si le malade délincor ne se soumettait
pas à cette obligation de soin et bien
malheureusement il retournait en prison
ici de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit de malad
qui sont bon alors on sait bien madame
le ministre l'a dit elle-même que le
malade mental il faut d'abord qu'il
prenne conscience de sa maladie et tous
les psychiatres le disent tous les
thérapeutes le
disent faire accepter par le malade le
soin et donc l'état dans lequel il est
c'est déjà un soin en soi-même c'est
déjà une thérapie et on voit bien que
cette démarche ne sera pas possible en
ambulatoire car en ambulatoire
pratiquement qui va contrôler la
contrainte qui les infirmiers des CMP
des des des établissements dont parlait
notre collègue ficher dans sa commune on
sait bien qu'ils sont très peu nombreux
et quand bien même on pourrait contrôler
quelle est la sanction quelle est la
sanction il n'y a pas de sanction à
cette contrainte la sanction ce n'est
pas le retour vers l'hospitalisation
d'office car l'hospitalisation d'office
ce n'est pas une sanction c'est un
soin donc on voit bien que ces soins
ambulatoires sans consentement pour des
malades mentaux qui n'ont pas commis
délit qui n'ont pas été jugés est
totalement impraticable et totalement
impraticable et donc je dirais que tous
les psychiatres que l'on interroge moi
j'ai interrogé les psychiatres de
l'établissement que je préside m'ont dit
ben on sait pas on sait pas ce que ça
veut dire on ne sait absolument pas ce
que ça veut dire comment
va-t-on contraindre un malade à des
soins en dehors
ou comment quand avec quel moyen tout
ceci est tout ceci est totalement
impraticable dernière question
si ces malades astreint à des soins sans
consentement à ambulatoire
Comè une infraction grave qui sera
responsable qui sera responsable bon le
le choc dans le public sera encore pire
que quand ilagit d'un malade qui est
hospitalisé et qui s'enf ou je sais pas
quoi parce que là il aurait été placé
par soin sans consentement en
ambulatoire il n'aura pas été contrôlé
parce que ça sera impossible et donc on
est à la je dirais à la mercie de toute
une série de dysfonctionnements graves
qui pèseront sur l'opinion publique bien
entendu et qui ajouteront la sécurité et
qui feront que cette mesure ne sera plus
appliqué en plus cette mesure elle
supprime ce qui existe déjà c'est-à-dire
les sorties
d'ESS lorsquun malade est hospitalisé
d'abord sans consentement et ensuite
lorsqu'on le sort de la procédure d'ch
mais qu'on le laisse dans un lit
d'hôpital si le psychiatre voit
l'évolution du malade et bien il peut
lui donner le permettre une sortie
d'essai pour voir comment il va se
comporter et puis après il reviendra au
bout de sa sortie et puis petit à petit
comme ça on le fera sortir de l'hôpital
la sortie d'ESS est supprimée c'est
terminé donc tout ceci est totalement
incohérent totalement inapplicable c'est
la raison pour laquelle évidemment nous
voterons compte comme nous l'avons fait
en commission par de fois et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons demandé
un scrutin
public bien Jean desissard puis Valérie
lard monsieur le Président mon
intervention sera courte car je souscris
pleinement aux arguments de mes
collègues en particulier mes collègues
Fisher et Leen qui ont présenté les
amendements l'obligation de soins est un
contresens clinique c'est un contresens
car on peut obliger un patient à être
hospitalisé mais pas à se soigner et
encore moins hors les murs d'un
établissement adapté c'est un contresens
car le travail d'un psychiatre est
d'amener le patient à vouloir se soigner
rien n'est précisé dans la loi sur la
forme que prendront ses soins hors de
l'hôpital il est impensable qu'il
s'agisse exclusivement de
l'administration de médicaments car la
guérison vient également de la relation
surtout de la relation la prise de
médicament ne doit pas être le principal
axe
thérapeutique le rôle du psychiatre ne
peut se limiter à la surveillance de la
bonne bonne prise des médicaments
n'aborder la psychiatrie qu'avec des
médicaments c'est considérer l'humain
que comme un être végétatif que l'on
traite comme tel sans aboutir à un
changement psychique profond on ne
réglera pas les problèmes de la
psychiatrie à coup
d'injection la véritable question est de
créer des places en accueil de jour
ouvrir de nouveaux lits et créer des
nouveaux postes dans les hôpitaux car
voilà madame la ministre la véritable
question la mise en place des soins sous
contrainte en ambulatoire vous permet de
faire des économies en évitant de
répondre aux besoins des hôpitaux mais
en faisant cela vous fragilisez encore
davantage des patients ayant des
trouples des troubles psychiques graves
c'est pourquoi je voterai pour ces
amendements explication de vote la parle
est
Val oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues simpement pour expliquer
quelle est la position de vote du groupe
sur les amendements 45 et 87 je ne vais
pas refaire la description du
cheminement en commission bien
évidemment de ce débat des amendements
qui ont été défendus par M GDI lors de
l'examen en commission mercredi dernier
des positions que j'ai prises
personnellement ainsi que Monsieur Milon
et d'autres de mes collègues ainsi que
une grande partie effectivement des élus
de la gauche ces amendements nous les
avons tous soutenus à l'article 1er en
tout cas tous ceux que j'ai cité et puis
quand il a s'agit de voter le texte nous
n'étions plus tous présents en totalité
ce qui fait que le texte n'a pas été
adopté on en est revenu à la position de
l'Assemblée ce qui fait ce qui fait non
mais je n'accuse personne je fais juste
le résumé de ce qui s'est passé en
commission d'accord alors ce qui fait
qu'effectivement dans l'entr-ettemps et
bien nous essayons de réfléchir à des
solutions qui permettent d'améliorer le
texte mais en tenant compte du résultat
de la commission de la fois dernière il
me semble que Monsieur Milon au travers
du travail qu'il fournit de ce qu'il
propose nous donne une solution qui
permet de cadrer effectivement ce qui
peut se passer à l'extérieur de
l'établissement ou en ambulatoire en
tout cas autre que dans des unités
d'hospitalisation à temps plein ou en
tout cas sur des modes des modes
alternatifs et que il y a moi en tout
cas sur cette amendement présenté par
Monsieur Milon et cet amendement qui est
sous-amendé par Monsieur Laurin il me
semble une solution qui permet
d'améliorer les choses de les cadrer à
la condition que madame le ministre nous
garantisse d'un certain nombre de choses
sur lesquel je rejoins mes collègues de
tous les bancs parce que je pense que
tout le monde est attentif à cela ce
sont les moyens qui seront mis en œuvre
pour assurer la bonne application de
cela les moyens qui seront mis en œuvre
pour assurer l'application de quelque
chose que le gouvernement soutient c'est
pas compliqué ce sont les moyens en
personnel paramédicaux je pense à aux
infirmiers psychiatriques qu'il faudra
recruter en supplément parce que lorsque
l'on dit que un programme de soins du
patient est établi par un psychiatre de
l'établissement d'accueil ça veut dire
que derrière si par exemple les soins se
passent à domicile par exemple il faudra
bien que des infirmières psychiatrique
agissent à l'extérieur de
l'établissement donc il faudra des
moyens supplémentaires parce que
lorsqu'on a des infirmières
psychiatriques dans l'établissement ça
correspond à un quotat précis de
personnel par rapport à un nombre précis
de patients si des infirmières sortent
pour accompagner des patients à
l'extérieur il manquera donc des
effectifs paramédicaux ça veut dire que
dans les décrets et dans les mesures qui
seront prises pour appliquer cet
amendement qui me paraît extrêmement
intéressant il faut un engagement du
gouvernement donc à augmenter les quotas
de personnel correspondant à ces mesures
dans les établissements qui seront
concernés et il faudra bien évidemment
aussi autoriser des personnels
paramédicaux des infirmières
psychiatriques à sortir de
l'établissement pour accompagner les
personnes à chaque fois que de besoin
voilà ce que je pouvais dire c'est que
encore une fois Monsieur Milon bravo
parce que vous avez essayé de sortir
notre commission par le haut par quelque
chose qui améliorera le texte
remarquablement il me semble parce que
ce n'était pas évident mais bien sûr
nous avons besoin des garanties du
gouvernement sur la façon dont nous
pourrons mettre en œuvre tout cela et je
pense en tout cas que pour notre groupe
nous n'avons pas souhaité aller jusqu'au
bout du redépô de nos amendements parce
parce qu'il nous semble que Monsieur
Milon a trouvé une bonne solution de
compromis mais le gouvernement doit
faire un pas un geste celui de s'engager
et y mettre les
moyens merci alors
nous nous reprendrons cela tout à
l'heure au
moment mon leain explication de vote sur
cela puisque nous reprendrons je dirais
l'intervention de Madame lettard au
moment où nous arriverons à l'amendement
d'Al
Milon donc je vous en prie monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues moi je voudrais quand même
qu'on on remette un peu les pendules à
l'heure pour l'histoire rapidement on
reproche à notre groupe notamment de pas
avoir voté le rapport la semaine
dernière je vous signale la semaine
dernière lors de la présentation des
amendements nous avions effectivement
voté un certain nombre des amendements
et notamment celui que j'ai représenté
ce soir au nom de mon groupe qu'on a
repris je l'ai annoncé tout à l'heure
labanement 87 qui supprime les alignéats
2 à 20 parce qu'il nous semblait des
amendements qui allaient dans le cadre
de quelque chose qui va profiter aux
malades pourquoi nous avons pas voté
nous avons fait une abstention parce que
les 3/4 même plus que ça de nos propres
amendements avaient été rejetés la
semaine dernière donc on n pas voté
contre on s'est abstenu prenant acte
dans le cadre de notre proposition la
semaine dernière de notre position aine
dernière qu'il y avait effectivement des
avancées hein et que nous allions donc
prendre acte en ne votant pas contre ce
qu'on fait par contre nos collègues je
pense du groupe communiste hein
justement pour prendre acte qu'il y
avait eu des avancées que nous avions
voté mais pour le reste la plupart de
nos amendements ont pas été ont pas été
retenus on allait quand même pas aller
comme ça apporter l'ensemble de nos voix
c'est au niveau de la majorité
sénatoriale qui est dans ce groupe que
les choses se sont détériorées et qui
ont fait que le résultat était ce que
l'on n ce que l'on aperçu donc nous
logiquement avant même de connaître la
position qui était celle de notre
collègue Milon qui pourra effectivement
être un amendement de repli nous avons
donc lorsque nous avons fait part les
amendements extérieurs présenter des
amendements qu'on avait soutenu la
semaine précédente qui était ceux
présenté par le rapporteur de l'époque
donc nous sommes tout à fait logiques
avec nous-mêmes dans ce cadre là tel que
je vous l'explique et je veux pas
revenir sur le fondement de cet article
de cet amendement 87 hein puisque je
l'ai fait dans le cadre de la
présentation hein c'est l'intérêt que
représentait cet amendement c'est de ne
pas confondre vitesse et précipitation
qu'il était encore tant dans le cadre
d'une grande loi de euh sur la Malie
mentale de réfléchir et en attendant on
éétait pas démuni puisqu'il y a
l'hospitalisation sans consentement qui
existe avec des sorties décès il faut
peut-être mieux encadrer mieux voir mais
qui fonctionne hein alors que là elles
sont complèement supprimé et qu'il y
avait donc urgence à attendre qu'il y
ait un texte meilleur dans son dans son
économie d'ensemble voilà notre position
très bien merci mais écoutez m chers
collègues je va vous proposer de passer
au vote je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public il va donc être
procédé explication de vote Président je
je demande une suspension de
séance vous voulez combien 5 minutes je
vous en donne
10 merci la séance est
suspendue la séance est
reprise j'ai été cisit de demande de
scrutin public par le groupe socialiste
et par le groupe crcspg sur les
amendements identiques 87 et 45
rectifié je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est favorable l'avis du
Gouvernement est défavorable il est de
procéder au scrutin pu dans les
conditions fixées pararticle 56 ceux qui
souhaitent voter pourettr au secrétaire
un bulletin blanc contre un bulletin
bleu s'abstenir un bulletin rouge le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants le scrutin est
ouvert
Dr
voter é
cl
j'invite mesdames les secrétaires à
procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
onous au et
on
ésult du scrutin 207 sur les amendements
45 rectifié 87 à l'article 1er nombre de
votants
338 nombre de suffrage exprimé 337 pour
l'adoption 51 contre 186 le Sénat n'a
pas adopté nous en arrivons à la au vote
sur l'amendement de Madame paayette et
Monsieur Dean qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est
contre pas adopté l'amendement de
Monsieur LEF numéro 5 deux avis
favorables présentés au nom de la
commission des lois qui est
pour qui est contre l'amendement est
adopté nous en arrivons à l'amendement
46 de Monsieur
ficher qui a reçu un avis favorable de
la commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement explication de vote je n'en
vois pas qui est
pour qui est contre alors on compte
attendez on va faire une vérification
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
debout parce que on voit pas je je
fatigue
alors
3 alors 4 13 sont ceux qui sont merci qu
sont ceux qui sont
contre 3 6 9 11 12 13 l'amendement n'est
pas adopté nous en arrivons sous
amendement de Monsieur Lauren sous
amendement
480 rectifié il a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et un avis
favorable du Gouvernement y a-t-il sur
ce sous-amendement des demandes
d'explication de vote madame David le
monsieur Le
Men pour l'instant s lesessard la parole
est à Annie David
oui monsieur le Président merci
simplement pour dire que nous ne sommes
pas du tout en accord avec ce
sous-amendement proposé par Monsieur
Laurin puisque si en effet nous pouvions
trouver quelques intérêt à voter
l'amendement de notre collègue Alain
Milon le
280 en l'occurrence cet amendement ce
sous-amendement pardon 490 réintroduit
ce qui nous semblait très mauvais dans
le le texte de loi à savoir que ce sera
bien un un décret en Conseil d'État qui
précisera les les conditions dans
lesquelles le programme de soins et ses
modifications sont notifiées aux
patients et transmis aux représentants
de l'État dans le département alors que
effectivement l'amendement de Monsieur
Milon évacuait ce ce problème là du
décret en Conseil d'État donc monsieur
Laurin nous a dit Madame la Ministre
également que le l'amendement 280 était
un très bon amendement je n'irai pas
jusqu'à dire que c'est un très bon
amendement mon cher collègue mais en
tout cas c'était un amendement
acceptable par rapport à à à ce
sous-amendement nous ne pouvons
évidemment pas voter ce sous-amendement
et si toutefois ce sous-amendement
devait être adopté il remet en cause
complètement le vote que nous pourrions
avoir sur l'amendement présenté par
Monsieur Milan parce qu'avec ce
sous-amendement il n'y a absolument
aucune réponse apportter au
questionnement d'ailleurs de tout à
l'heure de Madame Valérie lettard je ne
sais pas si madame la ministre nous
répondra ou pas sur les moyens bien
évidemment ici de toute manière elle ne
va pas nous dire qu'elle ne donnera pas
les moyens à ce texte de se de sa mise
en œuvre hein je ne pense pas que ici
elle va nous dire non non je ne vous
donnerai pas les moyens de sa mise en
œuvre donc elle va sans doute nous
affirmer que le gouvernement donnera les
moyens euh de la mise en œuvre de ce
texte mais ce sont des paroles et
au-delà des paroles j'aimerait bien
savoir ce que derrière ces paroles elle
entend proposer pour véritablement
donner des moyens à savoir le
recrutement d'infirmiers psychiatrique
par exemple mais pas seulement des
moyens financiers aussi pour les
ouvertures de lit dans les hôpitaux
enfin tout ce qui concerne la santé
psychiatrique tous les moyens que l'on a
demandé les uns et les autres enfin
surtout celles et ceux à assis sur les
bans de gauche les moyens un petit peu
aussi sur les bancs de mes collègues à
droite je ne vous ferai pas un mauvais
procès mes chers collègues mais quels
sont véritablement ces moyens que le
gouvernement entend mettre en œuvre donc
voilà sur cet amendement sousamendement
490 proposé par Monsieur Laurin nous ne
le voterons absolument pas et de son
vote dépendra notre vote sur le
280 merci la parole est à Jacy leain
pour explication de
vote merci monsieur monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre moi je suis
au nom de mon groupe dans le même état
d'esprit que notre collègue madame David
autant j'étais prêt je l'avais dit tout
à l'heure à reporter dans un de repli
sur la position présentée de compromis
de notre collègue mon autant et je l'ai
dit ce matin d'ailleurs de manière assez
longue en commission des affaires
sociales dans le Fourtout
décousu de la amendement présenté par
notre collègue Laurent qui fait rentrer
par la porte ce qu'on évacue par la
fenêtre ou l'inverse peu importe on n
pas de on n' pas de réponse à des
questionnements qu'on s'efforce
d'apporter depuis déjà pas mal de temps
avec en complément d'ailleurs les
problèmes qui sont liés au moyens on
pour raconter n'importe quoi hein s'il y
a pas de moyen on pourra pas faire des
bons soins et même pas d'ailleurs de la
bonne
sécurité la question qui a été posée
tout à l'heure par notre collègue léard
sur les moyens la question qui ont été
posé à Madame la Ministre j'espère
qu'elle va y répondre on ne fait pas de
la bonne médecine sans médecin sans
infirmier sans moyen sans l
hospitalisation sans li de repli là je
crois que faire croire le contraire he
c'est faire prendre des vaissis pour des
lanternes pour avoir géré pendant des
années et des années des établissements
hospitaliers on a porté bon parole au
moment où il faut faire des tableaux de
service quand vous avez pas des des
infirmiers ou des médecins pour mettre
derrière et bien vous pouvez pas soigner
bon après il y a des fugues des gens qui
prennent pas leurs médicaments et cetera
et cetera je veux dire que là il doit y
avoir des réponses claires elles ne sont
pas actuellement donné par ailleurs ce
qui a été souligné d'une manière très
précise très précise par notre collègue
Michel concernant la responsabilité dans
C ce type nouveau de soins sans cons
ambulatoire quand il y
arrivera une un accident un problème qui
sera
responsable qui sera responsable
j'attends toujours la réponse là-dessus
on crée une catégorie là juridique
nouvelle sans mettre en place
l'environnement c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure nécessaire pour que les
acteurs des soins qui vont avoir à
s'occuper de ces personnesl personnes
malades
puisse avoir une garantie au point de
vue de la
responsabilité on va partir dans les
procès sans fin en terme de
responsabilité on n'a pas de réponse
là-dessus alors pour ces différentes
raisons vous comprendrez et puis bien
d'autres ça serait trop long de
s'exprimer là-dessus dans l'occasion aus
de la soirée d'ailleurs demain ou
après-demain de revenir hein nous ne
pouvons pas accepter hein le
l'amendement le sous-amendement de notre
collègue Laurin
euh je crois que c'est ça tombe sous le
bon sens faut de temps en temps quand on
fait une loi avoir aussi le bon sens pas
de moyens pas de
soins pas de sûreté juridique en ce qui
concerne la
responsabilité c'est un signal pour tous
les dangers pour tous ceux qui
s'occupent des
malades merci pour l'exlication de vote
la parole est à Jean Desessard
oui monsieur le Président tris points je
suis aussi intéressé par
l'interpellation de Madame lettard à
Madame la Ministre quels sont les moyens
mis en œuvre
bon j'attends une explication madame le
ministre qui va nous dire effectivement
voici les moyens qui feraient que Madame
lettard dire ah je suis rassuré
franchement ça va bien fonctionner le
gouvernement qui maintenant fait des
économies dans tous les domaines et en
particulier dans la santé va débloquer
de l'argent pour c'est la mise en place
des soins ambulatoires donc là j'attends
cette révélation ce changement de
politique gouvernementale donc je suis
très attentif à la réponse de Madame la
Ministre et je suis persuadé que vous
aussi mes chers collègues le deuxième
point c'est le sousamendement de
Monsieur Lauren à à Monsieur sur
l'amendement de Monsieur Milon monsieur
Milon il mais une personne faisant
l'objet de soins psychiatrique sans son
consentement est pris en charge par tous
les outils thérapeutiques de la
psychiatrie adapté à son état et
Monsieur Laurin qui veut pas disent
qu'on va prendre des soins sans son
consentement dit il faut remplacer le
mot sans son consentement par auquel
elle n'est pas à même de consentir du
fait de ses troubles mentaux alors
là alors
là on va pas lui demander son avis parce
queelle sait pas qu'elle va être
exactement son avis on sait pas comment
elle va pouvoir répondre et tout ça
alors là
franchement très fort le monsieur
monsieur Laurin rapporteur pompier de
service par rapport aux difficultés de
la Commission et tout ça
bien ça
suffit 3ème point je ne voterai pas
l'amendement de Monsieur Milon même s'il
n'est pas sous-amendé par Monsieur
Laurent je l'ai pas voté en commission
et sur le deuxème point de Monsieur
Milon des unités alternatives à
l'hospitalisation temps plein des lieux
de consultation des lieux d'activité
thérapeutique et dans le lieu de vie
habituelle du patient j'ai défendu
l'idée qu'il fallait supprimer ces
alinéas je ne peut pas être d'accord
avec l'idée de soin psychiatrique sans
son consentement dans le lieu de vie
habituel du patient parce que ça oblige
à l'injection au médicament et je ne
vois pas quelle est la forme active que
pourrait prendre la relation et
justement entre le soignant et le
soigner donc c'est sous une forme habile
encore une fois et bien revenir à
l'esprit du texte initial même si
Monsieur Milon il l'agrémente d'autres
lieux où c'est possible mais on sait
très bien que principalement cela se
ferait au domicile du patient ou dans le
domicile de la famille et nous sommes
opposé justement à cette méthode
ambulatoire de soins psychiatrique sans
son
consentement merci alors Monsieur ficher
explication de vote oui je crois que que
c'est juste un complément par rapport à
ce qu'a dit Annie David bon nous avons
deux points qui sont
véritablement des points auxquels on
naapporte pas de réponse et on sait
qu'on ne les aura pas
pour débattre et dans peu de temps nous
débattrons des équilibres budgétaire
PLFSS après
PLFSS et bien c'est une réduction
véritablement des moyens qui sont donnés
notamment aux établissements de santé je
l'ai dit je les
répété la crise que traversent les
hôpitaux publics est certainement la
plus grave crise qu'ils n'ont jamais
passé il faut savoir que les directeurs
généraux des grands hôpitaux que ce soit
la PHP ou que ce soit les Hospices
Civils de Lyon j'allais dire que c'est à
la cravache que l'on fait respecter les
budgets et cela il faut véritablement le
dénoncer donc non seulement on a le
problème des moyens où nous n'avons
aucune réponse qui n'it apportée et nous
ne nous faisons aucune illusion
aujourd'hui la
psychiatrie se trouve notamment dans des
hôpitaux comme je prends les deux plus
grandes de l'agglomération lyonnaise que
vous connaissez très bien Madame la
Ministre que soit Saint-Jean de Dieu ou
l'hôpital le Vinatier et bien tous les
personnels avec toutes les organisations
syndicales sont
vraiment au cœur il y a des mouvements
de grève pratiquement à jet continue et
c'est un mécontentement qui vient et en
plus la responsabilité et bien on voit
bien qu'il y a un transfert de
responsabilité tout à l'heure on disait
que c'était je l'ai dit que d'une
manière ou d'une une autre ce sera une
manière et une façon de réduire la
dépense mais la responsabilité et bien
on la fera partagé par les familles et
cela c'est un des points sur lesquels
quand on connaît bien les familles qui
sont confrontées à la maladie mentale et
bien c'est ajouter de la souffrance à la
souffrance et je crois que c'est un des
points qui fait que on ne peut
absolument pas être d'accord avec le
sous-amendement et même si Monsieur
Milon d'une manière plus
intelligente si il connaît
ou tout du moins il tente de nous faire
entre guillemets
avaler son amendement et bien je crois
que là il ne faut pas s'y méprendre car
le fond du texte et bien c'est ce texte
que le Président de la République
voulait qui reste sera un texte avant
tout sécuritaire et après et bien nous
constaterons que les moyens ne sont pas
là que les personnels ne sont pas là
qu'il y a de plus en plus de lits fermés
et que les difficultés ne vont que
s'accroissant donc on ne peut que voter
contre merci alors madame la ministre je
me tourne vers vous pour la clarté du
débat puisque vous avez été interpellé
par Madame lettard par diff orateurs
est-ce que vous souhaitez répondre
maintenant sur les question des moyens
certainement monsieur le
Président merci mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs vous vous inquiétez à
juste titre sur la mise en œuvre de
cette loi même si les décrets
d'application seront progressivement et
à la au fur et à mesure de l'évolution
du texte seront préparé
euh pour qu'effectivement cette loi
puisse être opérationnelle dès le 1er
août euh
vous avez évoqué plusieurs
choses d'abord la question des soins
ambulatoires la question des soins
ambulatoires bien évidemment à chaque
fois qu'un programme de soins sera
identifié par le psychiatre hospitalier
qui décide de la possibilité de faire
sortir un patient et d'un suivi bien
chez lui et bien il faut un lieu faut
une équipe bien entendu il faut qu'il
ait cette garantie de se relais par des
professionnels au plus près du lieu de
vie de la personne les modalités
l'amendement mon précise il peut s'agir
d'un accueil de jour d'un accueil
thérapeutique d'un accueil familial
thérapeutique pourquoi pas des centres
d'activités
thérapeutiqu ce n'est pas simplement les
injections monsieur de zessard il ne
s'agit pas ici de la de la restriction à
l'alternative thérapeutique
médicamenteuse nous sommes dans une
approche globale de prise en charge et
en cela si je peux être rassurante bien
entendu derrière chaque malade il y aura
un référent qui aura lui la
responsabilité du suivi de cette
personne malade et qui sera bien entendu
en lien avec l'établissement dont est
issu le patient pour qu'il y ait un
échange et vous le savez très bien sur
le terrain comment ça se passe nous
avons des équipes qui fonctionnent entre
elles qui collaborent qui se téléphone
parce que l'objectif c'est que le malade
soit entouré qu' soit encadré et c'est
la responsabilité parce que les
professionnels font leur métier avec
beaucoup de passion vous en connaissez
j'en connais et ils ont d'abord le souci
du succès thérapeutique et il déploient
toutes leurs compétences au service de
leurs malades donc moi j'ai une grande
confiance dans les professionnels et je
sais et je sais qui seront ce coordonner
entre la structure hospitalière
qui décide d'un programme de soins qui
permet à un patient de retourner chez
lui avec les professionnels qui sont en
ville dans les CMP dans un accueil de
jour qui seront eux se faire le relais
de cette prescription hospitalière donc
bien entendu le malade ne sera pas
laissé pour compte et c'est d'ailleurs
et je voudrais s'il y aller tout
l'inverse de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec les sorties d'ESS qu'est-ce qui se
passe avec les sorties
d'ESS décide de faire un essai de
sortie le patient sort quel est le suivi
finalement quelle est la prise en charge
qu'il a derrière une surveillance nous
ditons une surveillance mais c'est une
surveillance qui est alléatoire on n'a
pas la garantie qu'il y ait ce suivi
rigoureux proche en tout cas avec la
garantie du du de la recherche de ce
succès thérapeutique la surveillance à
partir du où il n'y a pas cet engagement
du patient par rapport au médecin qui a
suivi ce patient s'il y a pas cet
engagement là on sait très bien que
l'adhésion l'observance du traitement
n'est pas
optimale alors mais si justement parce
qu'au moment où le patient sort il y a
cet engagement cet engagement mutuel
entre le soignant et le
soigné il y a cet
engagement% quoi vous
dites on garde le patient bon ben je
vais peut-être vous refaire la loi on
garde le patient en observation pendant
72 he durée pendant laquelle on essaie
par tous les moyens d'avoir cette
alliance thérapeutique et de faire que
ce patient
s'engage pour respecter un programme de
soin vous savez je le redis encore une
fois mais bon ça me paraît moins logique
mais un patient psychiatrique c'est pas
un patient qui est sans cesse de façon
continue dénué de conscience de son état
il y a des piqus et desvallé il y a des
moments où il y a conscience de son état
et puis a des moments où il n'a pas
conscience parce qu'il a décompensé et
donc pendant cette période d'observation
il y a on recherche justement on se
donne une journée supplémentaire pour se
donner pour donner au patients plus de
chance d'adhérer à son programme de
soins et c'est dans ce cadre quand on
sait que ce malade
dans ces périodes de lucidité
peut s'engager à un programme de soins
et à ce moment-l le le le psychiatre et
bien décide que le respect du protocole
sera
assuré bien évidemment donc je réponds à
Valérie lard derrière chaque malade il y
aura une équipe alors vous me dites les
moyens économie dans le domaine de la
santé alors vraiment là moi je je suis
estomaqué économie dans le domaine de la
santé mais ce n'est pas vous les
parlementaires qui votez chaque année
une progression de l'OND d'â c'est pas
vous qui chaque année avez voté une
augmentation de 2 milliards d'euros pour
les hôpitaux pour le fonctionnement
hospitalier c'est pas
vous et vous nous parlez aujourd'hui de
de de de baisse et d'économie dans le
domaine de la
santé c'est 2 % de plus dans le domaine
strictocensu de la psychiatrie cher
monsieur le sénateur alors alors non
mais alors arrêtez arrêtez de nous tenir
des discours selon lesquels on a une
réduction des budgets et on fait des
économies dans le domaine de la santé
puisque chaque année ce sont 2 milliards
de plus et si je fais un bref calcul
depuis 2007 nous en sommes à 10
milliards d'euros depuis le début de
cette mandature alors moi je veux bien
savoir où sont faites les économies mais
en tout cas ce n'est pas dans le cadre
de la loi de finance de la sécurité
sociale qui vous est soumise chaque
année et que vous votez chaque année
donc sur la question de l'augmentation
des budgets je n'ai plus rien n'apouvver
puisque vous êtes aux premières loges
pour savoir ce qui se passe donc c'est
vraiment de la mauvaise foi de votre de
de votre part donc bien évidemment dans
le cadre du budget qui sera voté chaque
année je l'ai dit un plan psychiatrie et
santé mentale est en cours de
construction avec les acteurs de la
santé avec professionnels les usagers
pour organiser le soin à l'échelle
territoriale ceci se fera d'ailleurs
comme dans les autres dans le cadre des
autres plans de santé publique il n'y a
pas de spécificité dans le cadre de loi
psychiatrie il y a des plans de santé
publique je vais pas les évoquer vous
les connaissez Plan Cancer plan
Alzheimer plan maladie rare plan lutte
contre l'obésité qu'on va là aussi sur
lequel nous allons travailler il y a des
des plans de santé publique et qui à
chaque fois ont une enveloppe budgétaire
pour la mise en œuvre des mesures qui
seront mis en application donc de ce
point de vue-là si ce si je peux être
rassurante et bien pour comme pour les
autres plan de santé publique le plan
psychiatrie aura les moyens pour la mise
en œuvre des mesures qui seront
identifiées avec les professionnels avec
les acteurs avec les organisations les
associations
familles sont dans la souffrance la
désolation voilà je crois que il est pas
de bon ton vous savez nous sommes là moi
je je suis ministre de la Santé la santé
c'est les malades et les malades c'est
mes concitoyens qui sont malades alors
moi les postures la caricature je crois
que les malades n'en tirent aucun
bénéfice de ces postures aucun bénéfice
donc nous sommes là moi je suis
favorable à des
propositions qui font avancer le débat
des propositions constructives le
sénateur Milon propose de clarifier les
mesures ambulatoires soit j'y suis
favorable le sénateur
Laurin propose de relarifier si ce n'est
pas encore clair dans cette loi et bien
le rôle de chacun soit allons-y vous
parlez des moyen le plan de santé
publique aura une enveloppe budgétaire
dédiée vous me parlez de la progression
des budgets vous les votez vous-même
chaque année il y a une progression des
budgets plus 2 % en 2011 pour la seule
psychiatrie monsieur ficher alors
arrêtez de N tenir des discours de
mauvaise foi donc voilà je crois que je
crois oui ben oui mais oui donc je crois
que j'ai suffisamment été clair j'espère
avoir été
rassurante et je suis à votre
disposition pour et bien je vous attends
d'ailleurs pour venir travailler avec
nous sur le plan de santé
mentale bien alors nous allons passer au
vote sur le
sous-amendement 490 rectifié mais j'ai
encore une demande d'explication de vote
de Valérie lettard qui n'est pas
intervenu sur ce sousamendement qui peut
donc expliquer son vote merci monsieur
le Président non tout simplement pour
dire à à norabra que
son explication de de vote me satisfait
son explication par pardon par rapport à
la question que j'ai posé sur les moyens
me satisfait pour deux raisons elle m'a
bien rappelé qu'il y aurait un
accompagnement derrière chaque personne
qui serait concerné par une prise en
charge ambulatoire c'est une première
chose un accompagnement devant chaque
personne non non non non mais monsieur
Fiser moi je demande deux choses un un
accompagnement devant chaque personne
qui soit garanti c'est pas forcément
évident chaque personne concernée une
prise en charge une personne référente
et une personne qui accompagne
deuxièmement excusez-moi j'ai posé la
question je peux dire si je suis
satisfaite ou pas de la réponse
satisfaire déjà satisfaite sur le
principe qui garantit qu'effectivement
chaque personne ne sera pas livrée
elle-même et deuxièmement sur ce que
Madame berad vient de dire sur le budget
et sur les débats budgétaires qui vont
être tenus à l'avenir et qui prendront
en considération les moyens financiers
nécessaires pour s'adapter à la règle
qui vient nous être dictée à savoir que
devant chaque personne il y a
l'engagement du gouvernement à ce qu'une
prise en charge adaptée soit financée et
accompagnée merci pas d'autre
explication de vote je mets au voie le
sous-amendement 490 rectifié qui est
pour
12 15 17 7 merci qui est
contre 7
8 alors le sous-amendement est adopté je
vais mettre au voix l'amendement 280
présenté par Alain Milon ainsi
sous-amendé y a-t-il des explications de
vote madame David madame la présidente
madame la Présidente Dini Jean Desessard
je serais très brve Monsieur H pardon
allez-y cher collègue je serai très brve
monsieur le Président simplement pour
dire que toutes les promesses que nous
avons entendu de Madame Nora Berra sont
donc pour les règles budgétaires futures
je vous rappelle quand même que ce texte
doit rentrer en application au 1er août
de cette année donc c'est au 1er août
qu'on a besoin de tous ces moyens c'est
pas lors des
prochaines aléatoires éventuelles
dispositions budgétaires qui pourront
qui pourront être mis en œuvre et dans
les moyens ce ne sont pas seulement des
moyens financiers au moment de la loi de
finance mais ce sont bien des PER
personnel dont on a besoin et les
personnels il faut pouvoir les recruter
les former et avant que cette formation
soit à son terme il y en aura sans doute
bien pour plus longtemps que les 3 mois
qui qui vont arriver voilà ils ont ils
ont supprimé vous avez supprimé madame
la ministre même si vous nous dites que
chaque année le budget est en
augmentation vous avez fermé des lits
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques vous
avez supprimé des postes d'infirmiè Py
psychiatrique donc tout cela il va bien
falloir le mettre en œuvre donc non nous
n'avons on absolument pas été convaincu
car vous ne nous avez donné aucune
mesure concrète hormis le prochain vote
du budget de la Sécurité sociale qui ne
sera qu'au mois d'octobre novembre et
dont on ne sait pas encore si oui ou non
il y aura dedans ce fameux plan pour la
santé psychiatrique donc nous ne
voterons pas monsieur Milon votre
amendement nous sommes bien désolés de
vous le dire nous vous aurions
d'ailleurs proposé pour pouvoir le voter
une un petit sous-amendement en vous
demandant de supprimer comme nous le
faisait remarquer très justement
Monsieur Jean de cessard dans le lieu de
vie habituel du patient car pour nous
c'est quand même un point qui nous
semble incontournable ne serait-ce que
par rapport à la sécurité juridique dont
il a déjà été question sur la
responsabilité de la famille par rapport
au patients qui seraient placés dans sa
famille donc nous vous aurions pour le
moins demandé cette suppression mais du
coup et bien ma fois nous ne voterons
pas cet amendement donc nous ne vous
faisons pas non plus de proposition de
sous-amendement
merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le
Président d'amendement celui d'Alain
Milon en sousamendement celui de
Jean-Louis Laurin intégrant celui de
Monsieur lecer on arrive à un texte en
léger progrès une personne faisant
l'objet de soins sans consentement
devient une personne qui n'est pas à
même de consentir du fait de son ses
troubles mentaux le protocole de soins
devient programme de soins le programme
de soins est à peu près défini mais
surtout le patient est informé de son
droit de refuser les soins et les
dispositions du second alinéa de
l'article 32 11 11 encore un petit
effort madame la ministre et les soins
ambouatoires ne pourront être prescrits
qu'à un malade formellement consentant
d'ailleurs je suis très étonnée par ce
que vous nous dites et par ce que vous
nous ne faites pas tout à l'heure là à
l'instant vous nous avez dit j'ai et
d'ailleurs j'ai suivi ce que vous avez
dit avec intérêt vous nous avez dit mais
au bout de 72 he le le psychiatre aura
obtenu le
consentement le consentement du malade
pour euh êre pour avoir des soins
ambulatoires pourquoi ne pas formaliser
ce
consentement dans le programme de soins
je n'arrive pas à comprendre si ce n'est
qu'il faut absolument afficher des soins
sans consentement je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi on ne peut pas
obtenir le consentement du malade qui va
être soigné à
l'extérieur bien sûr que ce malade peut
changer d'avis mais il aura quand même
eu un engagement formel et puis ben
c'est un malade il se peut qu'il n'ait
plus d'engage que son engagement il ne
le respecte pas mais quand même si on
lui lui demandait son avis si on lui
demandait de s'engager formellement il
s'engagerait et je comprends pas
pourquoi on ne le fait pas à travers ces
ces atonnement ces améliorations timides
on voit bien à quel point ce texte n'est
pas abouti et combien il aurait
nécessité d'approfondissement et de
réflexion c'est cela madame la ministre
que j'ai essayé de vous faire comprendre
à travers le texte que j'ai proposé la
semaine dernière à la commission des
affaires sociales mon amendement le
premier qui était présenté visé à ne pas
toucher aux sorties d'éessaiis pour se
donner le temps de travailler à une
grande loi de santé mentale que tout le
monde reconnaît nécessaire et appelle de
ses vœux vous l'aurez compris je
considère que cet amendement celui de
Monsieur Milon rectifié ne va pas à ce
loin malgré tout il me permet de penser
que les modifications que j'avais
proposé ont mis en lumière les
insuffisances et les approximations de
ce projet de loi je me réjouis qu'il ait
été amélioré tout en regret attend qu'on
a'ille pas plus loin n'étant pas
entièrement satisfaite par ces
modifications je m'abstiendrai sur cet
amendement comme je l'ai fait jusque- là
merci Jean Desessard pour explication de
vote
oui mais je remercie madame la
Présidente de la Commission pour son
intervention parce que j'ai cru rêver
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu madame la
ministre dire il y a des pics et des
valletes et puis s'installe une relation
entre le soignant et soigné bon j'ai C
comprendre je sais pas si c'est dans la
vallée ou le pic qu' y avait la prise de
conscience mais il y avait un moment un
consentement qui retombait un petit peu
après mais il y avait un moment un
consentement bon j'ai j'ai relu le texte
une personne faisant l'objet de soins
psychiatrique sans son consentement
c'est tout le texte je relis
l'amendement de Monsieur Milon euh
pardon là c'est Monsieur Laurin donc lui
auquel elle n'est pas à même de
consentir du fait de ses troubles
mentaux si on relit monsieur
Milon une personne faisant l'objet de
soin psychiatrique sans son consentement
c'est partout à aucun moment on dit il y
a une discussion dans un état on va dire
difficile qui permettrait d'obtenir le
consentement du soin à aucun moment
après on me dit mais ce sont pas des
médicaments alors qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est on sait que c'est
l'enfermement effectivement au foyer
dans la maison comment on va le traiter
que va faire le référent vous nous avez
dit bon il y a les sorties à l'essai
vous savez c'est à peine encadré hein
mais et là vous allez voir d'un seul
coup ça va aller beaucoup
mieux enfin pourquoi ça irait mieux
quelles sont les garanties c'est sans le
consentement c'est une situation qui
nécessite une urgence des soins et
d'ailleurs monsieur Laurin il détaille
hein le détail du traitement notamment
la spécialité le dosage la forme
galénique la posologie la modalité
d'administration et la durée est
prescrit sur une ordonnance ce sont des
médicaments mais comment vous voulez
faire autrement sans le consentement
enferm dans une maison il y a des
problèmes parce que s'il y a pas de
problème pourquoi il y a besoin d'une
hospitalisation alors c'est pas sérieux
on nous dit actuellement les sorties
d'essès on a à peine les moyens c'est
fait comme ça mais vous en faites pas
hein
entre pique et Vallé voilà là ça va être
sérieux la personne va être enfermée
chez elle besoin de soins médicament et
puis on va bien suivre ça parce qu'il y
aura référent quel est le référent à qui
va-t-il téléphoner le weekend
comment aujourd'hui tout le monde est
est très occupé quel quelle va être la
personne disponible pour se déplacer
quels vont être les horaires des
personnes qui suivent tout ça c'est pas
sérieux merci mon chers collègues gu
ficher puis madame la ministre
oui monsieur le Président pour ma part
je voudrais répondre à Madame la
Ministre car
elle vient de me dire que notre groupe
était de mauvaise foi et je dois dire
que c'est
inacceptable
moi c'est Monsieur ficher alors qui
était voilà qui est de mauvaise foi et
bien je ne l'accepte pas inacceptable
madame la ministre vous avez été
interrogé à raison sur la question des
moyens que le gouvernement entendait
mobiliser pour permettre une juste
application d'une réforme de la
psychiatrie et à cette occasion et comme
vous ne pouviez pas nous préciser
clairement la forme que ces moyens
prendraient vous avez affirmé que vous
que nous étions de mauvaise foi bien
Mo permettez-moi de vous dire que nous
sommes choqués de cette réponse et que
notre groupe ne vote précisément jamais
les plans de financement de la sécurité
sociale dont l'augmentation de long d'â
est un véritable trompleuil et nous y
reviendrons vous savez pertinemment que
cette majoration couvre à peine
l'inflation et l'augmentation prévisible
de certaines charges et des salaires et
vous nous demandez où sont faits les
économies et bien moi je vais vous le
dire ces économies sont faites de
partout avec la fermeture d' ablissement
de santé de proximité avec la
suppression massive des emplois publics
dans la fonction hospitalière mais dans
les trois fonctions
publiques et Monsieur Leonetti que vous
connaissez bien qui est votre famille
politique l'affirme lui-même en dehors
du secteur médico-social plus de 9800
emplois ont été supprimés dans les
hôpitaux publics en 2009 dont près de
5000 personnels soignants qui devrait
encore croître en 2010 au vu de la
contraction constaté de la progression
des dépenses de personnel dans les
comptes des hôpitaux publics et je
discutais pas plus loin que pas plus
tard que cette semaine où Madame
Bachelot a organisé avec Madame rossau
Debord et puis monsieur Jaca une réunion
sur la dépendance vous voyez que je n'ai
pas de hier j'y suis allé et là j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec le délégué
général de la Fédération hospitalière de
France il m'a dit ça va être
catastrophique et notamment les
suppressions d'emplois on peut penser
que on va notamment supprimer 15000
nouveaux emplois en
2010-211 alors là nous sommes en 2011 il
y en a à peu près 10000 et ça passerait
à 15000 en 2012 ce qui devient une
véritable Var d'ajustement et bien
là-dedans il y a les hôpitaux
psychiatriques là-dedans il y a les
budgets et là-dedans il y a les
personnels donc aujourd'hui à cette
heure-ci et bien croyez-moi que nous
reviendrons avec des exemples argumentés
et j'ai pris les notes notamment de ce
qu' a pu me donner le prés le délégué
général de la FF notamment sur les
suppressions d'emplois mais ça on le
tait vraiment mais la ré
est tout autre et c'est ce que nous
dénonçons
aujourd'hui merci nous quittons
l'hémicycle du Sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance je vous
retrouve cet après-midi à partir de
16h30 pour la suite de l'examen de ce
projet de loi relatif au soins
psychiatriqu très belle journée à
tous